sziasztok a következő vendégem pál
fikinga stílus és
színtanácsadó és mindenféle érdekes
témáról fogunk beszélgetni többek között
arról hogy mi történik egy
színtanácsadás alatt mit jelent a
testalkatellemzés valamint a
stílustanácsadás hogyan is működik
pontosan számomra is rengeteg új dolgot
mondott és tanított úgyhogy gyertek
tartsatok velünk és kérlek ne
felejtsetek el
[Zene]
feliratkozni szia kinga üdvözöllek a
podcastünk be szeretném a kedves
nézőknek bemutatni párfi kingát aki most
ebben a pillanatban mint stílustanácsadó
fog beszélni és és egy együtt fogjuk
majd boncolgatni a stílusnak a és a
színeknek a rejtelmeit de röviden
szeretném hogyha bemutatkoznál mert
annyival színesebb vagy mint ha azt
mondom stílustanácsadó rendesen
elpirulok mert ez csak egy kicsi szelete
annak ami aminek megismertelek úgyhogy
köszöntelek téged a műsorb szervusz
szabolcs örvendek hogy itt le ek gyere k
ilyen formában is ilyen formában is
gyere eg kicsit mutatkozz be hogyha most
ha a szakmai életedet szeretnéd
bemutatni egy pár mondatban akkor miket
említenél meg ebben a az elmúlt sok
évben amióta amióta én ismerem gyülnek a
ráncaim
igen
amikor előadást tartok akkor általában
azzal kezdem
hogy három fiú édesanyja tehát hogy
feleség és három fiú gyermek édesanyja a
legnagyobb mindjárt 16 a legkisebb
mindjárt ht és ott van középen lóánt
fiam aki 11 és fél
úgyhogy izgalmas ez az időszak és nagyon
meghatározza számomra nőként is hogy
három fiúnak vagyok az édesanyja meg hát
ugye a férjem a drága férjem és édesapám
is ott van az őzvegy édesapám aki
majdhogy nem hozzá tartozik a ő a
negyedik fiam adott esetben
a pszichológus vagyok mindig is a voltam
azt hiszem a lelkem mélyén és arról
szoktam mesélni hogy nem azért vagyok
ilyen mert pszichológiát végeztem hanem
azért végeztem a pszichológiát mert
ilyen vagyok biztos hogy segítő szakmára
születtem tehát hogy nem kérdés ez
számomra és azt hiszem a amikor anno
elkezdtünk képzéseket tartani közösen is
akkor tudtam még jobban megfogalmazni az
én saját missziómba azt hogy
valószínűleg az arra lettem hívva hogy
életminőséget növeljek hol itt hol ott
hol így hol úgy de hogy
alapvetően ha két szóban el kellene
mondanom hogy miért és mit teszek akkor
valószínűleg az lenne hogy életminőséget
remélhetőleg növelek
úgyhogy a pszichológiai
szaképesítésemre még ráhúztam a
projektmenedzsmentet ami ugyancsak
részem és azt nagyon-nagyon őrzöm és
szeretem mert édesanyámmal köt össze aki
ugye már nincs
ő volt ez a vér a családban és úgy érzem
hogy ez az ő öröksége bennem úgyhogy
azért is nagyon fontos ez nem csak a
különböző rendezvények események
szervezésében nyilvánul meg hanem uniós
projektek pályázatok írásában és
lebonyolításában is úgyhogy ezt is
nagyon szeretem
magamban de talán kerekké teszi vagy
egésszé az egészet az hogy hogy
stílustanács
vagyok igen hát a bloom bloom style
pontosabban
egy évvel ezelőtt indult ugye vagy
kicsivel több mint egy éve így van így
van szeptemberben múlt egy
éve mesélnél egy kicsit erről a
bloomstyleról hogy hogyan indult a a
gondolat maga amikor meg
megfogalmazódott benned hogy ezzel
szeretnél foglalkozni és hogy röviden
esetleg foglald ösze mi történt az
elmúlt egy évben ezzel a ezzel a
kezdeményezéseddel
akkor egy picit vissza kell mennem
ádámhoz és évához hogyha arról kell
meséljek hogy hogy indult ez az egész
mert nem derültékből villámcsapás volt
hanem hat éve hét éve hét éve indult ez
az egész bár akkor még nem tudtam hogy
ide fogunk megérkezni ugyanis hét éve
derült ki hogy veszélyeztetett
terhességem van a harmadik
babával és hét éve derült ki hogy
édesanyámnak kiújult a daganatos
betegsége úgyhogy hét évvel ezelőtt
novemberben amikor született a kisfiam
akkor kapta édesanyám az első kemó
kezelését és hát ez egy nyolc hónapos
közös utazás volt ahol én három
gyerekkel többek közt egy újszülöttel és
egy beteg
édesanyával voltam igyekeztem jelen
lenni nem tudom hogy akkor az
életminőséget kinél mennyire tudtam
emelni mert ez egy kimondottan nehéz
időszak volt tekintettel arra hogy nincs
testvérem nem lehetett erősen
felelősségemnek éreztem azt hogy ott
legyek édesanyám mellett hiszen ki más
hanem
én és ott volt a kisbabám aki mellett
anyaként ott kellett lennem erősen
hiszen ki más hanem
én nehéz volt ezt adott esetben össze
összehozni összeegyeztetni jól csinálni
az összes gyerekre figyelni meg esetleg
a családra is itt inkább ők figyelt rám
azt hiszem a nagyobb gyerekeim is meg a
férjem is rengeteget rengeteget
hátterezett mindazon által amikor
következő év augusztusában édesanyám
elbúcsúzott tőlünk és elment akkor azért
kellően megomlottam tehát minden amit
addig tartott az ember tudod ha lejár az
az állapot akkor így kész kimegy az erő
elmegy
minden és úgy szoktam mondani hogy
körülbelül úgy képzelem el most utólag
magam akkor mint egy ilyen hóvirág
akinek a feje a hóvirágnak amúgy is
csöng egy picit a feje de akkor teljesen
a sárba
voltm
és ez ugye augusztusb augusztusban halt
meg édesanyám és én de hát november
december elején fedeztem fel youtube-on
egy magyarországi stílustanácsadó a
közösségnek a
videóit annyira hitelesek voltak annyira
nőazonosak voltak és annyira nem
mesterkélten és nem ilyen influencer
stílusban beszéltek arról hogy milyen
nőnek lenni és hogyan segít egy-egy kis
huncutság jobban érezni magunkat a
bőrünkbe hogy megrakadta a figyelmemet
és elkezdtem gyakorlatba ültetni egy-két
ötletet amit hallottam a youtube
csatornájukon és működött az emberek
mondták hogy na hát hű milyen jó ez a
szett vagy milyen jól összeraktad vagy
tudom is én nyári hát hordtam
télderekán és lendületet adtak ezek a
visszajelzések lendületet adott szépen
lassan az amit láttam a tükörbe és akkor
az a hóvirágfej egy pindurkát mind
emelkedett tudod már egy idő után nem a
sárban lógott a feje és azzal ahogy én
emelkedtem értelemszerűen velem együtt n
emelkedett a családom is édesapám a
férjem de a gyerekeim is azzal hogy én
elkezdtem jobban lenni úgy ők is elkez
mi a mi kis világunk is elkezdett egy
picit jobban lenni és akkor mondtam hogy
én ide el kell
menjek szerveztem a barátnői kört hogy
négyen ötön lehetett menni csoportos
stílustanácsadásra és akkor szerveztem
hogy na kijön velem
pestre nos hát annyian lettünk a
négy-5tös csoportból hogy akkor
megfogalmazódott a kérdés hogy hát de
miért nem hívod el őket
ide és a projektmenedzser ugye jó
kihívásnak látta ezt a lehetőséget
úgyhogy
egy borongó estén írtam egy emailt
amiről fogalmam se volt hogy
egy budapesti stílus tanácsadónak
udvarhelyi isten háta mögött kettővel
van tehát hogy egyáltalán elolvassák-e a
levelemet hát nem csak hogy elolvasták
hanem eljöttek és szerveztünk egy turnét
ahol udvarhelyen vásárhelyen és
kolozsváron is megmutatták a stílus
erejét úgyhogy hat évvel ezelőtt indult
az én a stílussal való találkozásom és
kapcsolódásom akkor még nem
láttam talán méltónak és képesnek magam
arra hogy ezt a munkát
végezzem de jött az alpolgármesterséges
kanyar az életemben amit nem bánok bár
az árát rendesből megfizettem de tolta
ezt a
stílustanácsadói hát szakmát karriert
hivatást egy picit
azután viszont
amikor beláttam és megláttam azt hogy
nem ezen az úton kell nekem segíteni
közösséget hanem valahol máshol
másképp akkor
visszaköszönt meghirdettek egy
stílustanácsadói képzést és azt mondtam
hogy ez amikor minden egyértelmű amikor
tudod hogy abszolút ezt kell csinálni
mikorem most igen igen elvégeztem a
képzést és amiután megkaptam az
oklevelet mert tavaly augusztusban utána
szeptemberben indult a bloom hm kicsit
mesélj a bloomról hogyan indult meg
mivel is foglalkozik pontosan milyen
szolgáltatásokat biztosít ühüm nagyon
sokat gondolkodtam a nevén tehát a c
gpt-vel generáltattam neveket
végigvettem hogy a nevem legyen mi
legyen hogy legyen mint legyen és egy
ott meg azt éreztem hogy ez nem elég és
elmentünk nyaralni a mediterrán
vonalon júliusban és ott elképesztően
szép virágzás zajlott még és hibiszkusz
fák mellett mentem el többször és
egyszer csak így egy ilyen nagy
hibiszkusz virág így így szembe jött
velem és akkor ez a hát persze bloom
vagyis virágzás amikor kivirágzik egy nő
és a teljes pompáját szépségét
ugyanakkor egyediségét a saját színeit a
saját formáját a saját illatát mutatja
meg és ugye nem tudjuk azt mondani hogy
ez a virág szebb mint a másik hanem
mindenig külön szép és
egyediségében kiválóságában szép a
bimbótól egészen a a a kivirágzott vagy
már szépen lassan szirmait elengedő
virágig mindeniknek megvan a
különlegessége és akkor hát persze hogy
a bloom persze hogy virágzás a a neve
ennek a ennek a kis vállalkozásnak
úgyhogy így indultam el azzal a ásszal
amit kaptam a stílustanácsadás alatt a
képzés alatt ami azt jelenti hogy a szín
a elemzés színtanácsadás
testalkatelemzés a gardrob
rendezés stílus profil meghatározás ezek
voltak azok az alapcsomagok amikkel
indultunk amikkel
indultam és ennek tulajdonképpen van egy
keveréke ami maga a stílus tanácsadás az
alapstílus trén
amiben a szín és a testalkat egyaránt
benne van ez azért különlegesebb mert a
kettő szorosan kapcsolódik egymáshoz és
az a nő aki eljön az három és fél órát
ott van velem és ebből a három és fél
órából három órát nézi magát a tükörbe
ez már önmagában egy terápia mert sok
nőnek nincs is egész alakos tükre otthon
hogy egészben láthassa magát és ez egy
ilyen különleges helyzet és állapot
amikor meg megszűnik a külvilág és
megszűnik a külvilágnak a nyomása és az
elvárása nincsen a virágos mező összes
többi virága ott akihez hasonlítaná
magát folyamatosan hanem önmagában
önmaga szépségében jelenik meg és akkor
ezalatt az idő alatt azt fedezzük fel
hogy ő mennyire szép mennyire különleges
és azok a vonások amikkel ő rendelkezik
azok mennyire jól vannak ott ahol vannak
általában úgy jönnek be a az ajtón hogy
túl széles a csípőm túl nagy a hasam túl
kicsi a mellem túl kicsi túl nagy túl
rövid túl hosszú és akkor ezeket
mondják és úgy mennek ki hogy n hát
milyen szép vagyok és akkor ez az a nagy
változás az a metamorfózis ami ami ebben
a három és fél órában megtörténik ebben
a védett környezetben ez nagyon
megérintett amit most mondtál hogy és
azért érintett meg mert itt érzek
valamit amit érdemes egy kicsit jobban
kibontani
hogy a bimbózó virágtól egészen a full
pompájában levő virágig és azon túl
pedig amikor már hullatja a szirmait ez
egy ez egy ciklus de hogy mind ebbe a
ciklusb mindent lehet szépnek
látni sőt minden szép ha megtanuljuk
meglátni ezt a szépséget viszont a
nyugati szépség ideál most hogyha a
reklámokon keresztül látom magam előtt
minthogyha idealizálná a t -20 éves
testalkatú és kinézetű hölgyeket tehát
hogyha valaki fiatalabb mint 18 év akkor
idősíti és hogyha valaki idősebb mint 18
év akkor pedig próbálja fiatalítani és
ez néha olyan torz képet hoz sőt nem is
csak néha tehát hogyha azt nézem hogy
hány nőnek van olyan testalkata amit le
lehet fotózni lehet még azoknak sincs
olyan testalkata ak akiket le fotó akik
a kifutókon mennek akik a kifutókon
mennek és ez a tor szépségideál ez ez ez
hihetetlen nyomást helyez a nőkre
kicsit erről beszélnél nekünk hogy hogy
a bimbózó és a szirmait hullató virág
milyen hogyan lehet szép az ami nem a
mostani szépség ideálnak felel meg mert
gyanítom hogy most a nézőknek egy része
arra gondol amire nyilván én is
gondolnék először hogy itt
vagyok
középkorral néhány gyermeket megszültem
a testem sosem n lesz olyan mint 20
évvel ezelőtt amikor nézem a képeken
hogy nem is kellett figyeljek a
testalkatomra és milyen volt akkor most
pedig vértizzadva tornázom és igyekszem
hogy karban tartsam magam és úgyem tudok
olyan lenni lehet belőlem szép
érezhetem magamat szépnek hatlyan r csak
hogy lehet belőlem hanem az azt szoktam
elmesélni hogy igen tehát hogy
mindannyian hozunk magunkkal egy múltat
tapasztalatot értékrendet ott a
pogyászunkba mikor belépnek hozzám én
azt nem látom én csak ott és akkor azt a
nőt látom aki vagy akár férfit mert
férfiak is járnak tehát egy teljesen új
szemmel nézel rá friss abszolút abszolút
és ezt a szemléletet fogja ő is
megtanulni megtapasztalni a végére
amikor már nem a sebeit látja amikor
magára néz hanem az
értékeit mert igazából hogyha ránézel
egy nőre akár férfi ként akár a nő
nőként akkor talán nem ez az első hogy
hú de szép vagy hű de csúnyát nem is
tudnék mondani szerintem nincs is csúnya
nő ápolatlan nők vannak de csúnya nők
nem hiszem hogy lennének mert
mindannyian hozunk magunkkal egy múltat
mindannyiunknak a szemében ott van a
saját pogyászunk a saját tapasztalatunk
a saját megélésünk hogy nekünk mit
mondtak hogy milyen a szép hogy mit
láttunk mi szépnek hogy kit szerettünk
meg a ki szép volt hogyha az
édesanyánkra
gondolunk az ő szépsége és az ő személye
meghatározó mindannyiunk életében ugye
mit mondott nekünk hogyha férfiként
neked volt lánytestvéred vagy más nőkről
hogy beszélt édesanyád az meghatározza
azt hogy te hogyan tekintesz a nőkre
nyilván az édesapának is a a az ilyen
jellegű
megnyilvánulásai de hogy nekem mit
mondott édesanyám hogy engem lányként
hogyan szeretett hogy szeretette-e akkor
amikor kócos voltam vagy csak akkor
amikor amikor megfésültem a hajam hogy
szerethető voltam-e az értékeimért vagy
a külsőmért ezek mind-mind meghatározzák
azt hogy hogyan látjuk önmagunkat és
hogyan látjuk a
másikat és az hogy a médiában milyen női
kép jelenik meg ideálként ugye ez 10-20
évente változik tehát hogy most nem az
az ideál ami 20 évvel ezelőtt volt a és
20 évvel múlva nem az lesz az ideál ami
most van és 200 és 2000 évvel ezelőtt
sem az volt az ideál ami tehát hogy ez
folyamatosan változik és nem tudunk
minden ideálnak megfelelni és nem is
kell a szép nő önazonos a szép nő ismeri
magát ismeri az erősségeit tudja hogy mi
az ami különleges benne és ezt mutatja
meg mert és nyilván stílusos tehát hogy
nem
elrejtőzik nem háttérbe szorul hanem
megmutatja magát és ebben a
megmutatásban nem a kiabálás van a
köldökígérő dekoltás meg a fenékígérő
minizoknyával mert az már úgy kiabál
vagy azt szoktam mesélni hogy amikor
valakinek piros a cipője piros az öve
piros a nyaklánca piros a fülbevalója
piros a körme é piros a táskája is akkor
az már úgy érzed hogy ez kiabál ez sok
erre szoktuk mondani hogy izzadságszagó
mert biztos leizzadta míg megtalálta az
összes piros kiegészítőt hogy ezeket fel
vegye tehát hogy ez kiabál ez meglátod
az embert és oké köszi vettem minden
információt begyűjtöttem tovább mehetsz
ha valaki láttatja magát akkor felkelti
az érdeklődést akkor az az üzenete hogy
itt vagyok látható vagyok ez az én
értékrendem ilyen vagyok én ha szeretnél
többet megtudni rólam akkor abban már
neked is energiát kell befektetni hogy
megismerkedjünk hogy beszélgessünk hogy
ütköztessük a szemléleteinket és így
tovább
úgyhogy valahol talán ezt mondanám hogy
a szép az annyi mindentől függ függ
attól hogy mit mondtak otthon mit láttak
szépnek függ attól hogy engem láttak-e
szépnek függ attól hogy a párom engem
most szépnek lát-e függ attól hogy az a
közösség amiben vagyok milyen
értékrendet képvisel és ebben hogyan
tudok én
elhelyezkedni úgyhogy számomra nem
feltétlenül az a szép aki vékony és ezt
mindig szoktam mondani nagyon fontos a
hölgyeknek de a vékony a szépnek látod
amúgy stílusosnak jelenti bocsánat
stílusosnak lenni nem azt jelenti hogy a
lehető legvékonyabb formámat mutatom meg
hanem magamat mutatom meg lehet az egy
nagyobb méretű egy oversizakó vagy lehet
ez egy pullóveres tréningnadrágos
pillanatom is abban is lehetek stílusos
a kanapéra kucorodva egy csészeteával is
lehetek
stílusos de egy elegáns overálban is
lehetek magassarkóban stílusos tehát
hogy ezek mind részét képezik a saját
lényünknek és akkor tudunk szépek lenni
és visszatérve nem a szép nem a
vékonynőt látom szépnek én egyáltalán
hanem a környezetünk most mondja azt
hogy
a ha vékony vagy akkor nagyobb
nagyobb az esélyed hogy szép legyél és
egy nagyon sok lány ugye az anorexia a
bulímia egy csomó testképzavar innen
indul és szinte minden nőn testképp
zavara van éppen ebből fakadólag
hogy vékonyabbnak akar tűnni ja
emlékszem hogy nagyon érdekelt a
pszichológia már egyetem alatt is én
informatikát végeztem de belógtam a
pszichológiai egyetem kurzusaira és az
egyik kurzuson nagyon megragadt az
amikor azt mondta az egyik professzor
hogy azt látjuk szépnek ami egészséges
ami életképes ami vitális
és ezt ezt azért boncolgatom mert azt
tad hogy nem látod a vékonyságot szépnek
de azt mondtam hogy nem az a fokmérője
nem az a fokmérője visont y vékonynő is
lehet gyönyörű egy teltnő is lehet
gyönyörű pontosan de ez a kérdésem hogy
azért hogy ezt az illúziót a fejemben
most
így szétoszlassuk
hogy azért mégis csak fontos hogy milyen
testalkata van valakinek és vigyázz a
testalkatára abszolú tehát nem nem arról
van szó hogy akármit megehet mert úgyis
felöltözteti magát úgy hogy hogy
valahogy én ki így van így van abszolút
abszolút tehát az egészség a
legfontosabb és így van ami egészséges
az mindig gyönyörű lesz nem mindig az a
gyönyörű a ami egészséges most
gondoljunk a 2000es évek elején volt egy
nagyon erős trend a végtelenül vékony
nők a nem tudom hogy mond-e neked ilyen
két moss tehát hogy a kifutókon ezek a
szinte csontvázszerű szinte
csontvázszerű vékonyság é
például az indította el egy
nagyon-nagyon erős anorexiás hullámot
a velem akkor egykorú a fiatalnők
körében igen és erre mondom hogy bár az
volt a szépség ideál akkor nem volt
egészséges úgy ahogy az sem egészséges
hogyha nagyon-nagyon a elengedjük
magunkat és a az elhízásnak a különböző
szintjeit súrolgatjuk viszont egy nőnek
az élete főleg a hormonháztartása miatt
nem lineáris nem olyan egyszerű egy
nőnek hízni fogyni mint például most a
szó jó értelmében egy férfinak én nem
vagyok nutricionista nem vagyok
szakember hogy ezeket a dolgokat
boncolgassam viszont a magam életéből is
látom hogy egy férfinak 5 kgót meghízni
lefogyni hogy mondjam sokkal könnyebb
egy kis igen egy kis figyelemmel és egy
10-20%-os energia ráfordítással működik
egy nőnek a hormonháztartása és annak a
ciklikussága miatt az 5 kg majdhogynem
egy természetes változás két hét alatt
ha nem is öt de kettő igen úgyhogy
messze nem olyan könnyű ezeket
behatárolni és ezeket megmozgatni mint
egy férfi esetében hát meg a zsírnak más
szerepe is van egy nőítesben abszolút
abszolút és tekintettel arra hogy akár
az egészségvédelem akár az orvostudomány
egy nagyon maszkulin is hogyha megné
most is a nagyz szaktekintélyek
férfiak néha elvonatkoztatnak a a női
létnek a
természetszerűségétől hálistennek most
már egyre kevesebbet tehát most már
figyelnek arra hogy akár egy altató
gyógyszer másképp hat egy női
szervezetre mint egy férfi szervezetre
egy szívgyógyszer másképp működik egy
férfinál mint egy nőnél és ugye ezeknek
a gyógyszereknek a a kidolgozásánál akár
ritkán vették figyelembe a nőket pont
emiatt a nagyon-nagyon ciklikus és
nehezen kiszámítható hormonháztartás
miatt mert egy 18 évesnek egy 35 évesnek
és egy 55 éves nőnek a
hormonháztartása teljesenteljesen más
egy férfinál nem ekkorák a különbségek
és mondjuk egy ilyen klinikai
vizsgálatnál sokkal könnyebb volt
férfiakon vizsgálni gyógyszerhatást mint
nőket is figyelembe venni nos ezek neek
a hatását mint érezzük most hogyha most
akkor össze szeretnék tovább menni a
kérdésekbe de összefoglalnám azt amit
eddig érteni véltem
hogy ha most akármelyik személyt nézzük
önmagához képest van egy egészségesebb
fizikailag egészségesebb formája és egy
egészségtelenebb formája és egyre szebbé
válik valaki ahogy az ő egészségesebb
formája fele halad függetlenül az
öltözködéstől viszont maga az öltözet az
valójában összefügg az önbecsüléssel és
ugyanaz a személy lehet csúnya hogyha
úgy öltözködik ahogyan nem kellene
ahogyan ahogyan tegyük fel hibásan látja
magát és ugyanaz a személy szépé nem csú
láthatja magát csúnyának vagy láthatja
magát szépnek de ugyanaz a személy
csúnya nem lesz soha úgy értem hogy hogy
amikor ránézel a valakire látod benne a
potenciált a szépségre de tegyük fel azt
a potenciált hogyha a szépség az csak az
egy nagyon-nagyon szubjektív fogalom
tehát a saját értékeinek a megmutatása
vagy annak a hiánya mondanám én azt mert
nem tudom azt mondani hogy valaki csúnya
vagy szép hiá p pont erre értettem igen
tehát inkább hogy megmutatja-e az
értékeit vagy nem mutatja meg vagy
eltorzítja vagy akár csu csufatűz
paródiát tűz abból a a a potenciából ami
igen viszont megint csak
ez tudom hogy te szereted a radikál é
kifejezéseket viszont egy nőnek a lelke
a plusz 3 kgtól vagy plusz 5 kgó-tól is
össze tud ripityára
törni és az öt az még nem egészségtelen
az önmagához vagy a normális normális
testsúlyához a megszokott test
testsújához képest az 5 kg az még nem
lesz egészségtelen tehát hogy én nem
szeretném hogy azzal az üzenettel menjen
el egy nő most erről a a a a podcastet
meghallgatva hogy hogy ő vagy 10 kgóval
több mint amennyi kellene
legyen nem tudom kihez képest és akkor ő
csúnya és akkor ő csúnya igen viszont a
nők nem tudják hogy hány kilósak kéne
legyenek akár önmagukhoz képest sem van
egy testtömeg index ami jobb hián
behatárol
valahova így van ami behatárol valahova
de nem ezt fogja meghatározni hogy ő
egészséges-e vagy sem igen szóval hogy
ezt akartam összefoglalni akkor bár ebbe
a mondatba értsünk egyet hogy
egy személy önmagában szép vagy lehet
szép és ahhoz hogy tehát
inspirálódhatunk külső forrásokból de
nem érjük magunkat másokhoz amúgy ez egy
általános elv is hogy hogy nem érjük
magunkat csak önmagunkhoz a
múltunk belii énünkhöz
képest hasonlítsuk magunkat hogy egyre
jobbakká váljunk egyre egyre szebbeké és
egy kicsit belemennék ebbe a szépségnek
a különböző dimenzióiba ugyanis te is a
bloomon belül külön különböző
szolgáltatásokat biztosítasz az egyik
maga a testalkatelemzés a másik a stílus
elemzés és a a szín tanácsadás is ez
ennek része menjünk ezeken végig sorra
most például kezdhetjük a stílussal az
első kritika ami így amit hallottam
konkrétan például a férjek részéről hogy
rendesen sértésnek vették azt vagy akár
a hölgyek is veheték ezt sértésnek
amikor kapnak egy ilyen ajándékutalványt
hogy egy stílus tanácsadásra menjenek el
hogy hát mi az nem tetszik a stílusom
ühüm vagy hogy hogy hogy mit gondolsz te
rólam vagy ezt kicsit le kéne bontsuk
ezeket az előítéleteket mit jelent a
stílustanácsadás mi történik egy ilyen
alkalmon és és hogyan kell ezt
értelmezni hogy hogy ha most együ fel
valakinek vásárlunk egy ilyen
ajándékutalványt akkor hogy tudjuk ezt
odaadni úgy hogy ne ne sértésnek érezzék
hanem egy tényleg így ajándéknak
üüm ez egy nevelői munka is egyben mert
székelyföldön azért elég friss
szakmaként a a stílustanácsadó vagy az
szín stílus tanácsadó kevesen vagyunk
még én azt remélem hogy azért egyre
többen leszünk mert mert minden nőnek jó
hogyha egy picit új szemmel látja magát
a
tükörben ez történik mindenkinek van
stílusa még akkor is hogyha azt nem
fejezi ki vagy éppenséggel pont
rejtegeti amiről a beszéltem az előbb és
szerintem ez a legnagyobb véteg hogy nem
megmutatjuk nem mutatjuk meg magunkat
nem mutatjuk meg az értékeinket mert
ezzel meg
fosztjuk a többieket a lehetőségtől hogy
hozzánk kapcsolódjanak és hogyha jó
emberekkel kapcsolódunk vagy hozzánk
hasonszőrű emberekkel kapcsolódunk akkor
akkor mennyivel szebbé tehetnénk ezt a
világot amikor nem magyarázkodni kell
hanem érti a gondolatomat érti hogy mire
gondolok az az ember mert lát engem és
és hozzám akar kapcsolódni a
stílustanácsadás vagy a stílus
tréning az arról szól hogy megnézzük
azokat a küső jegyeket amik jellemzőek
ránk és azért különleges ez az egész
mert genetikailag meghatározott az hogy
milyen színű a szemünk hogy milyen az
arcbőrünk hogy milyen a hajunk színe ez
genetika de ugyanúgy genetika a
testalkatunk is mert a csontozatunk a
csontvázunkra az izmok és a zsíroknak a
lerakódása a megtapadása az egy
genetikai jellegzetesség és úgy ahogy
színeknél azt mondjuk hogy négy fő
színtípus van ugye a a tasznyyár ősztél
és ez az arcunk a kontrasztok az hogy
hideg vagy meleg színek állnak jól
világosak vagy sötétek esetleg erősek
tónusában erősek vagy visszafogottak
pasztelesek ez abszolút a genetika
határozza meg csak a mi édesanyánk nem
vett részt ilyenen hogy tudja hogy mik
azok a színek amik az arcához közel
igazán kiemelik őt és ugyanúgy mi is meg
kell tanuljuk ezeket vagy ki kell
kísérletezzük meg kell tudjuk határozni
hogy mi mik azok amik egyszerűen csak
megmutatják az arcunkat nem elrejtik nem
elfedik nem
beszürkítik hanem megmutatják éléné
teszik
életteljessé életerőssé és széppé ez a
színtanácsadás tulajdonképpen mi
történik egy ilyen színtanácsadás
elatttt színkendőket használok én is meg
a nyilván a többi stílust színtanácsadó
is tehát hogy színkendők segítségével
pont ezt a három tulajdonságot keressük
nézzük meg hogy hideg vagy meleg színek
állnak-e jól valakinek hogy inkább sötét
színek inkább világos színek ezek amik
ők őt igazán kiemelik illetve hogy a
telített erős vibráló vagy inkább a
visszafogott paszteles árnyalatok azok
amik igazán jók számára most hogy
mondjak ugye van ez a négy évszak
ráadásul ezek még keverednek egymással
tehát hogy én ősz típus vagyok és ezeket
úgy kell elképzelni pont mint az
évszakok a tavasz amikor a nap elkezd
sütni és elkezdi a melegségével a
természetet feléleszteni ezért a tavasz
ez egy meleg színípus éled a természet
még nagyon friss tehát világosak ezek a
színek még de már élénkek tehát ott van
ez a ez a zizegés a természetben
tavasszal amikor kimegyünk és azt
szoktam mondani hogy a tavaszt
elképzelni legkönnyebben ha úgy lehet
hogy ha valaki a holland tulipánmezőkre
gondol a az a színkavalkád az az élénk
friss vidám színvilág ami egy ilyen
tulipánmezőn látható azt hiszem ez
jellemzi a legszebben a tavaszt amikor
brokkolizöldek a bokrok a az a friss fű
megjelenik és az a melegség és az az
élénkség és az a világos színvilág ami
pompázik tavasszal na ezek a tavasz
színei nyár az már egy picit olyan
borongósabb tehát ott már megjelenik egy
ilyen szű keség amitől pasztelesek
lesznek a színek olyan mintogyha a nap
kivenné mint ahogy a kedvenc a élénk
színű pólunkat ha kint felejtjük a napon
egy picit megkopik a naptól ugyanígy a
természet színei is megkopnak egy picit
a tavaszi élénkség egy picit
visszafogott lesz ezért a nyár hideg
visszafogottabb pasztelesebb és ugyanúgy
megmarad ez a
világos
tipológiája aztán érkezik az ősz éppen
most forgatjuk ezt a podcastet ha
körülnézünk akkor olyan mint hogyha az
anya föld magához ölelne és egy ilyen
nagy ölelést adna az a melegség ami
megjelenik ilyenkor a mély sötét nagyon
intenzív színek amik megjelennek a
természetben meleg telített és egy picit
sötét a hát részben telített igen és és
mindenképpen sötétek azok az árnyalatok
amik megjelennek az erdőszéli fáknak a a
levélszínei ezek mind a rozsdától a
egészen a narancssárgáig a mélysárgáig
és aztán érkezik a tél ahol megjelennek
a nagyon erős kontrasztok a hófehér hó
ami szikrázik a sötét fakéreg
a szoktam mondani hogy a fenyőfazöld a
székelyfenyőfának a zöldje az a mély
méregzöld a magenta az összes ilyen
nagyon-nagyon erős ha bemész
egy sportboltba és végignézed a
sífelszereléseknek a színét na azok a
télnek a színei a vibráló élénk hideg
színek jelennek meg ilyenkor télen és
nyilván magasak a kontrasztok is úgyhogy
ezért hideg élénk és egy picit sötét
színek jellemzők a térre na és aztán
ezek mind keverednek egymással hogy ne
legyen egyszerű és a közös
tulajdonságaik erősödnek fel ilyenkor ez
nagyon érdekesí egyből az első
gondolatom ezzel kapcsolatban az volt
hogy mi mennyire szimmetrikus mennyire
szépen rendeződik hogy meleg hideg meleg
hideg így egymás után és genetika a
személyiségünkkel összefüggnek ezek a
színek tehát érdekes módon jellemzőink
vannak
személyiségben amik megnyilvánulnak a
színeinkben és forí hogy látsz egy ilyen
összefüggést például hogy a hideg szín
az tegyük fel az introvertált
személyeknek a
a van a színek a a színeknek a p ol
ológiája egy picit bonyolult mert ugye
amikor egy színre gondolunk akkor a
legjellemzőbben ugye a a nem is a nem
színeket szoktuk ilyenkor felhozni a
fehér és a fekete a nyugati kultúrában
egészen más szimbolikával bírnak mint
például az ázsiai vagy a délkeleti
kultúrában például a gyásszíne például a
gyásszínei pont felcserélődnek ugye igen
a de az elegánciát a finomságot tehát
hogy vannak jellemzők
amik amik kultúál meghatározottak és
valahol becsepegnek és bejönnek
mindannyiunk életébe de hát ugyanezt a a
az elméletet ezt a keretrendszert lehet
alkalmazni négerekre is például abszolút
igen a fekete a fekete bőrű nők férfiak
esetében is ugyanúgy megjelennek ezek a
kontrasztok ugyanúg vannak tavaszok
nyárok télek ősz ősz színvilágok
ugyanígy megjelennek abszolút mert attól
hogy a bőr színe fekete attól a
pigmentációja egészen más és a
kontrasztok egészen másak benne és lehet
egy meleg barna szemszín és lehet egy
hideg majdnem feketébe áthajló szemszín
és akkor ez teljesen más
színekkelutat jól hí pszichológusként
nagyon kíváncsi vagyok a véleményedre
így ahogy jársz az úton egyrészt azért
rálátsz tehát ugy ránézel egy emberre és
úgy érzetformma hogy ez most az a
személy most meleg nyár kéne bocsánat
nyár kéne legyen és tegyük fel nem őszi
színekben van őszi színekben van ez az
egyik és a a ez a jó maradjunk ennél a
kérdésnél és mindjárt felteszem a
következőt a nagyon egyértelmű a tiszta
tehát amikor például a hidegszín típusok
találkoznak vagy a meleg szí típusok
találkoznak ott könnyebb mert lehet hogy
nagyobb a diszonancia amikor valaki
mondjuk teljesen meleg szín típus és
hideg szín színű
a ruhadarab amit hord de nem ilyen
egyértelmű és koppintott már az romra a
színkendő és mondta hogy hm várjál
várjál mert nem biztos nagyon sokat
befolyásol a a festett haj is például
vagy a festett szemöldök vagy hogyha
valaki
a az ajkát is tetoválja és akkor lehet
vagy egy más nagyon erős rúzst használ
vagy nagyon erős a a sminkkel bármilyen
szintípust ki tudunk hozni tehát annyi
minden változó van ami ilyenkor közb
szólhat hogy hogy de én egyébként is azt
szoktam mondani hogy munkaidőn kívül nem
dolgozom tehát hogyha megyek az utcán
nem azt nézem nem az ragad meg hogy
mondjuk nem a jó szint hordja hanem
sokkal inkább az ragad meg hogy milyen
szép valaki apró apropó festett ha
valaki akkor rosszul is meg tudja
választani ezt a színt persze és ha
ránézel úgy érzed persze munkaidőn kívül
de hogy érzed hogy hogy hogy ezt lehet
hogy inkább barnára kellett volna fesse
nem vagy nem barnának nem erre az
árnyalatára tudod pont azért mert
pszichológus vagyok vagy nem tudom hogy
azért érte
annyi minden van és erre akartam kitérni
színeknél hogy lehet hogy számára az a
szín ad
biztonságérrzetet mert a színekhez nem
csak azt kapcsoljuk amit amit a
társadalom elvár tőlünk hogy a zöld szín
nyugtasson meg a sárga legyen az
irigység színe satöbbi hanem az
élettapasztalataink hiszen ha
körülnézünk színekkel vagyunk körülvéve
bárhova nézünk színeket látunk és
életünk során olyan sok tapasztalatunk
van amit lehet hogy önkéntelenül is
színekhez kapcsolunk például
gyerekkoromban hogyha nekem nagyon
megütöttem magam és édesanyám
egy kékszínű ruhában volt amikor odajött
és nem megszídott hanem megvigasztalt
pedig valószínűleg pont olyat csináltam
amit nem lett volna szabad és a
vigasztalása az óvása a szeretete az ami
akkor körülöl el lehet hogy
önkénttelenül ahhoz az árnyalatú kékhez
ezt fogom kapcsolni és mindig ha nem áll
jól is az a kék lesz a kedvencem és
amikor biztonságra szeretetre óvásra
vágyom akkor azt a kéket fogom felvenni
hát ki a turúó vagyok én a színtanácsadó
az idegen nő aki azt mondja hogy nem ez
az árnyalatú kék áll jól neked hanem a
másik és ezt ne hordjad én soha nem
mondom az embereknek hogy ne hordjanak
egy színt mert inkább csábítod hogy mi
mi az ami talán lehetne inkább azt
mondom hogy jó de akkor használj egy
olyan színű rúst melléje vagy tegyél egy
fülbevaló ami egy picit lehet hogy azt a
h hideget egy picit enyhíti rajtad de ha
neked az ad
biztonságérzetet akkor akkor azt hordjad
és sokszor ők se tudják hogy ez a szín
kapcsolódik egy élményhez vagy amikor
megszitták vagy amikor az első szerelmi
csalódását megélte most mondok a saját
életemből egy példát a férjem nyolc évig
erdőmérnökként olyan munkahelyen
dolgozott ahol nagyon sokat volt
távol nagyon sokat volt különböző
helyiségekben erdőkben éppen ezért pont
olyan zöld és földszínű árnyalatú ruhái
voltak ugye a munkaruhái amik egyébként
az én színeim tehát én egy lágy ősz
színtípus vagyok vagyis az ősznek és a
nyárnak a találkozásában vannak az én
színeim és a mostani zöld árnyalatok
minden ez a terepszínű zöldtől egészen
el a sárgás zöldig ezek mind jól állnak
nekem de gondold végig hogy hányszor
láttál engem ilyen színű zöldekben pedig
már egy jó ideje ismerjük egymást
kevésszer mert bennem ezek a zöld színek
elsősorban az ő munkájához és
távollétéhez kapcsolódnak amikor nekünk
két kisgyerekünk volt
úgyhogy hiába állnak a legjobban a
stílustanácsadónak azok a színek hogyha
ő már tudatosan én már tudom hogy emiatt
de még mindig barátkozom és néha-néha
hozom be ezeket a
színeket hogy mondjam meg másnak aki nem
pszichológus és lehet hogy nem gondolta
így végig ezeket a dolgait hogy márpedig
ezeket a színeket hord vagy márpedig
azokat a színeket ne hord sokkal több
van bennünk tehát nem
valósan
nem csak
test és lélek vagyunk és elme ugye test
elme már az orvostudományban azért a
testelme is meg a biopszichoszociális
modell is nagyon-nagyon fontos helyet
kap de nem csak ennyi vagyunk az
élményeink a tapasztalataink az
emlékeinknek az összessége is vagyunk
ugye és ezt mindig figyelembe kell
vegyük és mindig amikor valakihez
nyúlunk ez egy tényleg ez egy segítő
folyamat amikor valaki bejön hozzánk nem
az a cél hogy még jobban a földbe
döngöljük és azt mondjuk hogy mit szabad
és mit nem hanem hogy teret engedjünk
neki kibontakozni és önmagát megtalálni
ez nagyon jó példa volt amit amit
ezekkel az őszi színekkel mondát valóban
tényleg nem njon emlékszem hogy ilyen
színekbe láttalak volna most van egy
kicsi zöld rajta tehát hogy igen így
lépésenként a deszenzitizálom magam
tehát hogy az élménytől próbálom
leválasztani a színt mert a szín szegény
nem hibás azért az élményér és
tapasztalatairt illetve azért az
összekapcsolásért ami az én fejemben
történt meg most már így nagyon sok szín
elemzés után nagyon kíváncsi vagyok hogy
mi a te tapasztalatod vagy egyáltalán
mit tanultál erről hogy ez ezek
arányosan oszlanak meg tehát mondjam úgy
hogy a
25%-a a tehát vagy akkor hogy képzeljem
a székelységnek egy mondjuk tekintélyes
része ősz és akkor egy szűk kisebbsége
mondok egy egyszerű példát bár
nagyon-nagyon általánosítás lesz ez is
skandináv ország világos bőr kékzem
szőkehaj inkább a nyárnak a tipológiája
ugye tehát hogy ezek a jellemzőik
nemzetként mediterrán vidék olívabőr
sötét haj sötét barna barna szem barna
haj tehát eleve nem tudnak ugyanazok
lenni vagy az ázsiaiak ugye a
porcelánfehér bőr sötét szem sötét haj
ott sokkal több a nagyon hideg
kontrasztos színtípus a mediterrán
égővön sokkal több az inkább meleg
inkább telített színtípus tehát hogy
változik a genetikánk függvényében
hogykor melyik a leggyakoribb b
székelyföldön nálunk inkább a tél a
hidegebb színtípusok de igazából
tavaszból volt viszonylag kevés tehát
hogy a tavaszint típusból volt kevés és
az őszből sincs olyan sok tehát úgy
inkább a a
télnyár tengely de ugye ez ez változó
pont kacagtuk más szintntanácsadóval
beszéltük hogy hogy amikor
megfogalmaztam hogy milyen rég nem járt
tavas szintn típus nálam arra jött három
egymás után szóval ez
ilyen na ez változot és a idővel is
változik tehát tegyük fel most ahogy ő
sszülök egyreká nem fog úgy fogsz
őszülni úgy fogok őszülni igen igen a
színtípusodnak megfelelően és ha
lebarnulunk sem fog változni tehát hogy
ha barnább lesz a bőrünk akkor itt a
színpalettánknak az erősebb élénkebb
színei fognak nagyon jól állni abban az
időszakban de nem fogunk egy másik
palettáról áthozni színeket akkor sem
viszont még egyszer hangsúlyozom hogy
nekünk nőknek sokkal könnyebb játszani a
színeinkkel
mert a fehér nem az én színtípusom ez a
tört fehér már inkább viszont egy
melegebb saját színvilágomhoz találló
rúzssal és egy fülbevalóval én máris
egyet csavartam és tudom irányítani a
figyelmet férfiak esetében ez nehezebb
mert ugye kevésbé nyúlnak a sminkhez de
hogy férfiaknál inkább fontos
megpróbálni a saját színeket behozni
mert mi nők tudunk játszani vele de
mindig elmondom hogy egy nő arcán a
legszebb a legesleszebb kiegészítő az a
saját mosolya és hogyha ő egy színben
jól érzi magát még akkor is hogyha az
nem az övé de mosolyog tőle akkor az
sokkal fontosabb mint az hogy én
meglátom az utcán és azt mondom hogy
ennek a színnek az az árnyalata jobban
állna neki mert az én vagyok és rólam
szól nem róla a mosoly viszont abszolút
róla szól igen ez ez ez
tényleg amikor én vettem részt ezen a
színtanácsadáson akkor értettem meg
mélyebben hogy hogy ebben tényleg van
valami tudod úgy székely férfiként engem
sosem tanít sőt az ellenkezőjéire
tanítottak pontosan hogy mintogyha tehát
annyira feminin a színekkel foglalkozni
hogy egy igazi férfi sosem foglalkozik
azzal hogy milyen színben van hanem
minden mert vagy piperkötsz vagy igen
igen és amikor a kendőket így
rakozgattuk egymás mellé megdöbbentett
hogy ugyanaz a szín nyilván nem ugyanaz
egy egy árnyalat nélkül de más
árnyalatban ugyanaz a színnek más
árnyalata más jellemzőj és és tényleg
ahogy ahogy mondtad hogy most ez és ez
eközött és valahonnan felsej lett a
semmiből hirtelen egy érzés hogy hogy ez
más és hogy éreztem hogy amit mond tehát
hogy hogy valami tudod gyakran az is
bennem van a művészetekkel kapcsolatban
régebb rengeteg ilyen előítéletem volt
hogy amikor valaki teljesen oda van egy
festményért hogy milyen gyönyörű ezek a
ennek a színhasználata és kicsit olyan
snobnak éreztem hogy vajon ez
ez nem-e nem egy megjátszá vagánykodás
vagy tényleg ott van-e de azt hiszem
hogy hogy van valami amire meg kell
tanítsam magam meg kell tanuljam látni
ezeket a dolgokat és ezek ott vannak és
rejtetten így é úgy is befolyásolnak
anélkül hogy
tudnám úgyhogy számomra egy egy nagyon
meghatározó élmény volt és aztán másik
meghatározó élményemet elmesélem a
stílus és testalkatelemzésnél mindjárt
megkérlek hogy y kicsit bontsuk ki azt
is mert mert azt hiszem itt a székely
égbe el kell hozzunk egy újabb üzenetet
ezért is hívtalak
meg valamit még mondanál-e így a
színtanácsodás igen a székelységgel
kapcsolatosan jutott eszembe hogy azt
fogalmaztam meg egyébként hogy
ugye ott van a még mindig a
posztkommunizmust éljük bár már 35 éve
annak lassan hogy ahol megtanítottak
szürkének lenni ahol megtanítottak
egyformának szürkének egyszínűnek lenni
mindenki a maga területén a saját színé
kellett vigye még a boltos néni is de a
székelység is hasonló mert
az én
nagymamám 19-20 éves volt amikor férhez
ment az anyai nagyanyám és
akkor rögtön szabályszerűen az összes
fiatalság és hajadonsággal együttjró
minta és színvilágot félre kellett tegye
és meg kellett öregedjen a sötét
telített színeket kellett elkezdje
hordani a kendőiben a kötényeiben a
konyharuháiban mindenben már nem
lehetett hajadon tehát hogy a szín az
egy nagyon erős meghatározó volt a nők
életében kategorizált hogy hova tartozol
függetlenül attól függetlenül attól hogy
egyéniségében és személyiségében az a nő
hol volt vagy tehát hogy 18 1920 éves
nőket küldtek 45-50 éves korba
percek leforgása alatt férfiak esetében
ez nem történt meg tehát a férfiaknál ez
a szín jellemző nem jelenik meg fél
fiatalember a hajadon és és nős férfinél
tehát hogy hát gyakorlatilag színek
tehát voltak vannak színes színbeli
különbségek a fiatal és az idős között a
férfi
nem népis nincsen nincsenek nincsenek a
nő nőiben vannak a nőiben vannak a
nőiben vannak igen és hogy a a nőiesé
kibontakozását mennyire megnehezítette
ez is és mennyire nehezíti ez is hiszen
még mindig ilyen végletekben
gondolkodunk illik nem illik szabad nem
szabad és a színekkel is pont így
vagyunk kell egyáltalán a férfiak
foglalkozzanak a színekkel mert most
végig nőkről beszélgettünk abszolút
abszolút igen arról meséltems minket nem
használnak a férfiak de egyértelmű tehát
hogy még egyszer visszatérek oda hogy a
stílus azt jelenti hogy megmutatom magam
ez a közép tehát az egyik véglet amikor
elbújok ami a ttinnédzserekre jellemző
adott esetben bő kapucni is sötét szín
most önmagammal vagyok elfoglalva ugye a
saját identitásomat kell kialakítsam ez
náluk oké de amikor egy férfi mondjuk 35
évesen és egy-két gyerekkel a
tarsolyában és a családjában még mindig
így öltözik és elbújik és nem magát
mutatja meg
mert így szokás vagy mert a a férfi az
mindegy hogy mit vesz fel mert legyen
fér téer korabeli ruhái vannak vagy még
mindig azok a ruhái vannak meg igen vagy
mondjuk tréningnadrágban járk el a
világban holott a tréningnadrág az egy
sportoláshoz kifejlesztett ruhadarab és
nem igaz hogy nincsenek kényelmes
felnőtt férfi ruhadarabok is de az egy
egészen más üzenetet hordoz és sokkal
inkább láthatatlan marad mint egy olyan
férfi aki tisztában van azzal hogy
milyen a testalkata mik a számára
előnyös színek és egészen másképp
jelenik meg a világban én azt szoktam
mondani a férfiaknak hogy méltóvá kell
válni ott lenni annak a nőnek az oldalán
aki aki téged választott és úgy tudunk
méltóvá válni vagy úgy tudnak vagy úgy
tudtok férfiként méltóvá válni hogy
kihúzzátok magatokat felismeritek az
értékeiteket és ezeket
megmutatjátok nem csak a nő miatt hanem
önmagatok miatt is mert akkor
megteremtitek azt a felületet ahov
kapcsolódni tudnak mások is és megint
csak én abszolút meggyőződésem hogy a
világ akkor tud jobb lenni hogyha mi
egyenként kicsiként a saját világainkat
egy picit jobbá tesszük ez viszont csak
akkor lehetséges ha látszunk ha nem
látszom ha elbújok ha elmenekülök a
felelősség elől akkor úgy könnyű nem az
én hibám nem én tehetek róla nem tudom
befolyásolni ha láthatóvá válok akkor
ezek a kifogások már nem nem van nem nem
jelennek meg
nem tudok már ezekre támaszkodni hanem
akkor fel kell vállalnom önmagam igen
egy kicsit a maszkulin oldalról is
szeretném megközelíteni ezt a a stílus
kérdést én körülbelül olyan három éve
kezdtem el tudatosan inget hordani nem
kis részben a feleségem hatására de de
az egyik közeli barátom hatására is és
azelőtt nagyon frusztrált ez a kérdés
hogy miben öltözködöm egyrészt pont
amiatt mert a ruhatárom egy része még a
koromból marad hátra egy örökségként
sosem figyeltem erre mert egy feminin
dolognak tartottam azt hogy hogy nem nem
is vásárolni öltözni igen tehát
kényelmetlenül éreztem magam hogy
bemenjek egy üzletbe és minél hamarabb
menekülni akartam abból az
üzletből valamint tehát amiatt mert túl
akartam esni ezeken a a ruhákon vagy
ruhadarabokon se a stílusára se a
színére nem figyeltem és utólag jöttem
rá hogy volt amikor két-három számmal
nagyobb pólót vagy vagy vagy vagy
pulóvert vásároltam magamnak voltak ha
ha volt in rajtam akkor mind az
ünnepléssel volt asszociálható tehát
hogyha elmentünk egy esküvőre akkor vett
inget és akkor az esküvőn kívül pedig
olyan kényelmetlen volt meg volt egy
csomó ilyen hazugság is amit bemeséltem
magamnak hogy hogy kényelmetlen az ing
meg hogy hogy égeti a bőröm az ing
és szóval de de rá kellett jöjjek
praktikus módon hogy tényleg a stílus
az hogy hogyan öltözködöm és hogy
gyakorlatilag hogyha egy elegánsan
öltözködöm a jobbik éemet hívja elő úgy
ahogy mondtad olyan mint hogyha egy
gyönyörű nő hívna minket arra hogy
táncoljunk és mi méltóak kell legyünk
arra hogy hogy táncoljunk az ilyen az
esztétika ilyen a szépség hogy egy
jobbik énünket csalogatja elő
és most praktikusan úgy fogalmaznám meg
hogy az elegáns stílusus öltözködés
bizonyos szempontból funkcionális is
például az én esetemben abszolút az
tehát a ha most elmegyek egy tárgyalásra
valójában a tárgyalás alatt én a céget
képviselem a csapatot képviselem nem
önmagamat képviselem feltétlen és ezt az
értékrendet tehát hogyha én egy pólóba
megyek el és azt akarom ezzel üzenni
hogy nekem annyira nem számít az
öltözködés hogy én a a a ttinédzser
életemnek az egyik pólóját még mindig
hordom ennyire egyszerű vagyok ennyire
nem adok erre a a francos öltözködésre
valójában pont hogy azt a szervezetet
húzom le akit képvis tehát ilyen
szempontból én uniformisban vagyok és és
képviselek valakit és és meg kell
feleljek ennek és ha azt akarom hogy
hogy megtiszteljem azt a csapatot aki
kőkeményen dolgozat és a teljesítményét
kell bemutassam akkor gyakorlatilag
értüköltözködök és értük öltözök fel meg
önmagadért is ugye a saját
értékrendednek a megmutatásáért hiszen
nagyon-nagyon fontos tudatosítani
magunkban hogy abban a pillanatban
amikor mi kilépünk az ajtón otthonról
abban a pillanatban mi üzenünk a
világnak a testünk az ahogy felöltözünk
de az is ahogy a hajunkkal bánunk vagy
ahogy ha megmosakszunk vagy nem
mosakszunk meg ha hajat mosunk ha nem ez
egy nonverbális a legnagyobb
nonverbális
üzenőfelület amikor kilépsz az ajtón
azzal ahogy felöltöztél üzensz a
világnak ha akarod ha nem ha tetszik ha
nem tehát ha felöltöztél ha nem öltöztél
fel és úgy méz ki a világba az is egy
nagyon erős üzenet de valószínűleg akkor
a pszichiátriai osztályra visznek de
hogy alapvetően minden egyes pillanatban
amikor megjelenünk a világban akkor
üzenünk van aki nek a csápjai jobban
finoman hangoltabbak és hamarabb megérti
ezeket az üzeneteket viszont például az
üzleti világban ott hát a gondolj bele
hogy a az ügynököket arra is megtanítják
hogy az autójuk milyen kell legyen akkor
amikor or elmennek egy céghez a
képviseletben nem véletlenül alakultak
ki ezek a vizuális elemek amiket
hordanak a feliratozotting a kis logó a
cégnek a színei tehát nagyon-nagyon sok
minden van és már nagyon rég felismerték
hogy hogy ez egy nonverbális
üzenőfelület és nem csak akkor amikor
egy céget képviselünk hanem amikor
önmagunkat képviseljünk mert mi is
legalább annyira értékesek kell legyünk
hiszen ha egy cégben vagyunk egy
közösségben vagyunk valaki mellett
vagyunk valamilyen mikro köz neek a a
képviselői vagyunk minden egyes
alkalommal és az ahogy megjelenek a
világban az rólam
beszél az önazonosságomról az
értékrendemről van amikor nem rólam
beszél például amikor eg egy ilyen ruhát
hord egy rendőr az nem a az
önazonosságáról szól hanem a
funkciójáról szól de akkor is fontos
tehát maga a ruha az az konrét egy
meatározó és megkülönböztető jegy tud
lenni ugye ez van ez amikor tinorban a
rocker vagy a különböző csapatokhoz
kapcsolódunk és és azt erőteljesebb az
igény hogy a kapcsolódást és a valahova
tartozást kifejezzük a ruháink által
úgyhogy napokat lehetne mesélni csak
arról hogy mit fejezünk ki ilyenkor de
még egyszer mindennek a kulcsa az
önazonosság tehát tudok úgy elmenni
pólóban egy
tárgyalásra hogy az még stílusos elegáns
legyen és érezzük azt hogy megtisztelem
az üzlettársamat is meg megtisztelem
azokat is akik a hátam mögött vannak és
dolgoznak ugye akiket én képvis elek
mert hogyha az a póló egy szép tiszta
fehér póló amire ráveszek egy zakót
akkor abban a pillanatban és mondjuk nem
egy farmernadrággal vagy az a
farmernadrágn világos kék hanem sötét
kék akkor abban a pillanatban már
egészen másképp jelenik meg a póló mint
amikor egy tréningnadrággal veszem fel
és egy melegítő felsővel igen hát ilyen
szempontban azért vannak olyan
stílusbeli nógózónák ahova például az
egyik ilyen a rövidujuing ugye hogy ha
jól értem a rövidujuing y nem létező
dolog tehát az az
iparosodással ugye az iparosodással jött
be ahol a férfiek jellemzően ugye a
nagyapáink is még ingbe jártak és akkor
a ahogy a bekerültek a gépek mellé az
ingnek az ujja balesetveszélyessé vált
és akkor így jelentek meg így fel
kellett tűrni hát igen és aztán levágták
az egyszerűség kedvéért de én azt
szoktam mondani hogy ha valaki nem james
bond film casting castingra megy és
akkor a rövidujuing nem tapad a izmos
felkarjára akkor jobb elkerülni azt mert
jellemzője az anyagnak hogy ha bő az
anyag és abból valami kilóg akkor az
mindig vékonyabbnak fog tűnni tehát egy
ávonalú szoknyában a nőnek a lába mindig
vékonyabbnak fog tűnni ugyanígy a férfi
felkarja is vékonyabbnak fog tűnni egy
bő rövidujú inkben és hát a férfiasság
an nem feltétlenül ezt a jegyet keressük
hanem hanem a férfias kart és egy hosszú
j in feltűrve sokkal szebben megmutatja
még akár egy vékonyabb férfinak a karját
is mintogyha egy rövidujuinkben
lenne úgyhogy kedves hölgyek lehet
lebeszélni a férjeket a rövidujuingről
és kedves urak nem igaz hogy csak a
rövidujuink kényelmes a hosszú ujuink
feltűrve is vannak még ilyen gyors
tippeid hogy mik azok a a a a területek
ahova nem szabad menni tehát hogy a ez
most egy példa volt amire emlékszem igen
igen egy másik példa az hogy a férfiak
jellemzően a kényelem jegyében egy-két
számmal nagyobb ruhadarabot vesznek a
férfiaknak is testalkati különbségeik
vannak öt alap testalkatípus van férfiak
esetében is és annak függvényében hogy
mik a
jellemzők különböző szabásvonalak
lesznek inkább kényelmesebbek és inkább
előnyösek tehát hogy egy nadrágnál
hogyha valakinek a dereka hangsúlyosabb
és teltebb akkor nem egy számmal nagyobb
nadrág fog segíteni a kényelmesed
találni hanem egy jobb szabásvonal
aminek egy picit fennebb jön a a dereka
az lesz számára az igazán jó mert ami a
derekán jó lesz az a lábán nagyon-nagyon
bő lesz tehát meg fog rottyanni hátul a
fenekénél és nagyon-nagyon bő lesz a
lábán tehát hogy ha valami szűk nem azt
jelenti hogy egy számmal nagyobbat kell
venni hanem lehet hogy egy más szabá
vonalat kell nézni ami ugye egy férfinál
eleve a vásárlás miatt külön kihívás de
most már annyi jó szakosodott bolt van
ahol tanácsadók vannak és elmondják hogy
mire kell figyelni meg hát nyilván ha
stílust tanácsadóhoz mennek akkor meg
tudjuk azt mondani hogy inkább milyen
típusúra figyeljen am tehát hogy a másik
az amikor inget és zakót vesznek akkor
nekiállnak és ak mindenféle sport
bemelegítő gyakorlatnak állnak neki
minthogyha minimum egy kézilabda a
meccsre készülnének abba az inkbe és
zakóba holott nem ez a szerepe tehát
hogy és akkor nem jó szűk várban és
akkor megint egy számmal nagyobbat
vesznek tehát hogy ez egy nagyon gyakori
hiba amit látok hiba nincs ahonnan
tudjuk tehát hogy mivel nincs nincs
transzgenerációs stílus múltunk mert nem
foglalkozott ezzel sem a nem
foglalkoztak a szüleink vagy nem
foglalkoztak ezzel a nagyszüleink
úgyhogy nincs ahonnan tudjuk nem is
hibáztatom a férfiakat sem és a nőket
sem de hogy érdemes ezekre figyelni és a
nadrághossza nálad ez nem szokott
probléma lenni mert magas vagy viszont
nagyon sok férfinál a farmerernadrágtól
kezdve megrottyan a szára a ahol
találkozik a a lábával a talpával és nem
kellene tehát álló helyzetben a nadrág
pont a lábfejig kell lejöjjön hogy ne
rottyanjon meg állóhelyzetben tehát hogy
arra érdemes figyelni én pont az
ellenkezőjtől szenvedek hogy még talán
lehetne egy pár centivel hosszabb igen
igen és a női divatci divatcikekben de a
férfi ruházatban is most már megjelentek
a tol például ugye a magasaknak a a
gyártott ruhadarabok úgyhogy akkor ezt
kell keresni
hm itt van egy mítosz ami ottlenga
szerintem sokaknak a fejében amikor
amikor ezt hallgatják ezt a beszélgetést
mégpedig az hogy nekem már megvannak a
ruhadarabjaim otthon és akkor most ki
kell dobjam az egészet tegyük fel hogyha
most kiderül hogy se színbe se szabásba
nem felel meg hogy ez annyi pénzbe fog
kerülni hogy nekem erre nincs pénzem mit
mondanál ennek a a személynek aki ezt
gondolja pont először megkérdezném hogy
hány százalékát hordja azoknak a
ruháknak amik ott vannak a szekrényében
utána megkérdezném hogy milyenek azok a
ruhák mert az úgy nem nagyon állja hogy
a 20 évvel ezelőtti eddig elnyűt
nyakopólomat még mindig fel tudom venni
mert mert ebből általában el tudunk
indulni főleg nőknél tapasztalom azt
ahol mondom sújban is meg szerepekben
élethelyzetekben nagyok a fluktuációk
hiszen gondoljunk bele hogy egy nő
általában eléri a fiatalkora csúcsát
aztán anyává válik ami azt mondom hogy
egy terhességi ciklus egy nő testében és
hormonháztartásában akkora változással
jár 18 hónap alatt tegyük oda a 9 plusz
k-et ugye a kilenc hónap a az
állapotosság é kilenc amíg
visszakerül amennyit egy férfi jó
esetben egy ember életen keresztül
megtapasztal és ez csak egyetlen egy
terhesség és akkor utána ezzel
megváltoznak az élethelyzetei nem biztos
hogy ugyanolyan munká át fog végezni nem
biztos hogy ugyanott fogja végezni lehet
hogy vállalkozóvá válik lehet hogy
otthonról fog dolgozni tehát nagyon sok
minden változik a a nőnek az életében és
a ruhatára nagyon sokszor nem változik
vele együtt de férfiaknál is ugyanígy
jellemző ez amikor azt mondjuk hogy a
tinéori ruháiban mert méretben még
mindig jók és akkor miért cseréljem le
hát azért mert megváltozott az
élethelyzeted mert egy egészen más szere
körnek kell neked megfelelni mától vagy
tegnaptól vagy öt évvel ezelőtttől és te
nem vetted fel ezt az ívat ha férj
lettél ha apa lettél ha olyan irodai
környezetben dolgozol ahol dresscod van
ha tárgyalni jársz ha ügyfelekhez jársz
ha klienseid vannak akkor ugye két
másodperc alatt ennyi eldönteni hogy te
oké közelebb jöhetsz vagy nem és hogyha
azt mondják hogy nem jöhetsz közelebb az
első benyomás után akkor nagyon sok idő
és energia amíg teépíted ezt a fals első
benyomást és miért pazarolni az időt és
az energiát olyasmire ahol ott lehetne
ezeket sokkal kreatívabban használni
igen er emlékszem hogy volt egy amerikai
kliens akinek a szemén láttam hogy kb 40
másodperc alatt döntötte el hogy akar-e
velünk dolgozni vagy nem azt nézte hogy
ingbe vagyok hogy a háttérben egy
rendezett iroda van és hogy elég jól
beszélek angolul ha most egy pólóban
lettem volna otthon úgy hogy a füles
rajtam van é a háttérben látszik hogy a
szobámból dolgozom gyanítom hogy nemet
mondott volna 40 másodperc alatt így van
és mondom ezeket ezeket a döntéseinket
nagyon-nagyon hamar tehát ugye itt a
hippotalamusz pillanatok töredéke az
ősagyunk hozza meg ezeket a döntéseket
és jaj én nem olyan vagyok hogy az első
benyomás dehogyne mind ilyenek vagyunk
amit tehetünk az az hogy tudatosítjuk
ezt a folyamatot de alapvetően
mindannyiunkra hat az első benyomás ez
az első két másodperc amíg meglátunk
valakit még csak kezet se fogtunk és nem
is hallottuk a hangját és már akkor
döntünk egyet ebben a 40 másodpercben
már benne van jó esetben ugye a kézfogás
vagy a köszöntés üdvözlés a hang a
hanglejtés a nyelvhelyesség satöbbi
pedig én gyermekkoromban azt tanultam
hogy nem a ruha teszi az embert pedig
igen pedig igen láthatjuk hogy
igen abban a korban nőttünk fel mi
amikor amikor a ruhák ly keveset
tehettek rólunk én emlékszem
határozottan hogy a ugye kaptuk a
ruhákat örököltük jó esetben és volt egy
nagyon szép téli kabát hát én nem tudom
nyolc-kilc éves lehettem és emlékszem
hog kicsi ilyen bund része volt egy
barna kabát volt és az egyik telet úgy
jártam végig abban a kabátban hogy nagy
volt szegény édesanyám mind próbálta
hogy az ujját tűrje fel mert hosszában
nem volt annyira látványos de válban é
újban igen a következő térlre pedig már
kinőtt tehát a növekedési ciklusom az
nyárra esett és a következő télen meg
idáig értehát hogy nem volt egy telem
amikor élvezhessem azt a
ruhadarabot és ez leri rólunk egy
férfinál is egy nőnél meg meg még inkább
hogy hogyan jön ki a
házból hogyan zizeg a világban tud-e
másra figyelni vagy azzal van elfoglalva
hogy szorítja szűk pecsétes nem tetszik
nem előnyös nem az ő szín satöbbi ez
meghatározza azt hogy hogy van jelen
aznap a a a a világban hogyan figyel és
mennyi türelme van a gyerekeivel a
munkatársaival a férjével a párjával a
barátaival tud-e az lenni aki észreveszi
a másikon hogy nincs jól és akkor azt
mondja hogy gyere főzök neked egy
kávét vagy pont az lesz akinek kávéra
lesz szüksége és érdekes mertát ugye a
pszichológia
különböző kutatásokat végeztek hát főleg
a szakmai vonalon hogy egyrészt mennyibe
telik felöltözni reggel egy nőnek
másrészt az hogy ha rosszul indul a nap
akkor az meg tud-e változni a nap végére
és érdekes módon nem tehát ha rosszul
indul a napod amit még megfejelsz azzal
hogy tehát kiöntöd a kávét odasül a
gyerek reggelije tudom és én kiejtesz
mindent a kezedből és hogyha te ezt még
megfejeled azzal hogy olyan ruhákat
választasz ki amiben nem érzed jól magad
különböző okokból kifolyólag akkor nagy
valószínűséggel a napod ugyanilyen rossz
hangulatban fog zajlani és ugyanígy fog
lezárulni azt mutatták ki hogy ezeknek
az embereknek enyhülést csak az hoz
hogyha hasonszőrű rossz hangulatban lévő
emberekkel beszélgetnek és megtárgyalják
hogy ki van rosszabbul de minimum 10%-os
teljesítménycsökkenéssel jár minimum 10%
teljesítmény csökkenéssel jár az a nap
több szünetre van szüksége szétesett nem
tud úgy odafigyelni és a többi és a
többi ha neked viszont jól indul a napod
lehet hogy odaégett a a reggeli és
kiöntötted a kávét de legalább felvettél
valami olyant tudod mint amikor rossz
keded van és beteszel egy ilyen happy
playlistet a ruháid egy picit
összekapnak akkor megnöveled az
esélyeidet abba az irányba hogy jobb
legyen a napod jobb lesz a teljes ményed
nagyobb lesz az eredményességed
kevesebbet fogsz kiabálni a gyerekeiddel
több lesz a türelmed a körülötted
lévőkkel és lehet hogy pont akkor pattan
be az az ötlet amikből milliókat fogsz
csinálni szóval érdemes jól felöltözni
reggel most mondhatnám azt hogy jól van
kinga kedves
stylist ezek
pszichológiai tények könnyű azoknak akik
sokat keresnek de nekem nincs annyi
pénzem hogy én most ezeket mind
megcsináljam mit mondanál erre jól
öltözni nem pénz kérdése hálistennek
most már egyrészt nagyon fontos a
tudatosság ugye hogy olyan ruhadarabokat
vásároljak amiket fel is veszek mert
ezzel egyrészt a pénzemet jól fektettem
be és jól amortizálom mert ha én
többször felveszem ugyanazt a
ruhadarabot akkor a hordási értéke az
egyre inkább csökkenni fog
és nekem az a célom hogy ha én veszek
most mondjak 100 leér egy pólót vagy egy
bluzt akkor én azt legalább 100szor
tudjam felvenni hogy egy lejbe kerüljön
nekem a hordása ugye ühüm ez az egyik
tényező a másik tényező pedig az hogy a
ruhaipar azt hiszem hogy a harmadik
legszennyezőbb iparág a
földön ami azt jelenti hogy minden egyes
megvásárolt nem hordott és két év múlva
kidobott ruhadarabbal
tulajdonképpen tudatosan és szándékosan
szennyezem és ártok a földnek tehát
minden egyes alkalommal amikor jól
választom ki a ruháimat akkor a földet
óvom és hogy ez hol kapcsolódik hogy van
vagy mennyi pénzem van vagy nincs ott
kapcsolódik hogy egy pólót hogyha
megtanulok három-négyféle módon hordani
vagy egy zakót vagy egy farmernadrágot
különböző szettekbe berakni azzal sokkal
többet fogom hordani azt a ruhadarabot
tehát a pénzemet jól fektettem be
másrészről
pedig nem fogok annyit termelni mert ha
megvettem hát ez majdnem jó ugye jól van
az úgy ez a másik ilyen székely
jellegzetesség ó mindegy jól van és
nincs jól mert felveszed felpróbálod és
akkor levetted és mégis felveszed azt
ami tényleg jó nem csak majdnem
jó és egy idő után kidobod azt a
ruhadarabot mert valahol hallottad hogy
gardrobot kell rendezni és a gardrob
rendezés az abból áll hogyha egy évig
nem hordtál valamit az kidobod pedig nem
feltétlenül így van ez jóval
összetettebb ez a történet és akkor
szennyezed a földet éppen ezért én
mindenkit biztatok arra hogy egyrészt
outletekből másrészt pedig secondhekből
vásároljon és itt már az ár messze nem
az az ár tehát hogy nem a pénznek a a
hiányáról beszélünk amikor ezekben a
boltokban ezek online is a de fizikailag
is fizikai boltokban is ott vannak tehát
hogy hihetetlenül jól fel lehet öltözni
outlet vagy secondh típusú
boltokból ha önazonosan azt közvetíted
ami és aki te vagy
igen hát köszönöm a a a választ mert
meggyőztél a következő kérdésem pedig az
hogy és igen nem eldobjuk a
ruhadarabjainkat hanem udvarhelyen is de
mindenhol be kell írni már nem tudom
pontosan hogy hogy van de vannak ilyen
recycling helyek ahova az elnyűt
elhasznált pólót is nem a nagy szemétbe
dobjuk hanem ezekbe az
újrahasznosító kukákba tesszük tehát
hogy nem adén ezekel a ruhákkal tudod
ezeket feldolgozzák vagy különböző
termékeket gyártanak belőlük tehát hogy
külön külön feldolgozás külön min a
petpackokkal vagy mint az üvegekkel hogy
it itt működik a igen romániában is
működnek ezek igen tehát nem a karitasz
kukába kell eldobni mert onnan megint
csak az általános szemétbe jut hanem ott
valóban azokat a darabjainkat kell adni
amit már nem hordunk de még mindig
kiváló állapotban vannak ugyanígy el is
lehet adni most már nagyon sok felületen
lehet eladni ruhadarabokat de hogy erre
is figyelni kell hogy hol
újrasznosítjuk ezeket a textíliákat ha
tetszik ez az epizód akkor kérlek
iratkozz fel a csatornánkra vagy írd meg
kommentbe hogy milyen más témáról
hallanál még szívesen az egyik dolog ami
hát személyesen nekem nehéz volt főleg
így székelyként meg hogy nem beszéltem
jóró románul felkerültem kolozsvárra
bennem volt egy görcs és talán még most
is van egy görcs bemenni egy üzletbe és
románul beszélni valami olyasmiről amit
amúgy sem értettem és és se a stílusom
nem volt tiszta se a szín skála nem volt
tiszta hogy mit keresek és akkor egy
olyan nyelven kell elmondjam amit nem is
értek feltétlenül nem tudom kifejezni
magam szóval rengeteg görcs összegyűlt
bennem és emiatt a ruhatáramban is
rengeteg olyan ruha ami nem odaillő és
talán nem is használtam görcsös
ruhadarab gs ruhadarab
úgyhogy gyanítom hogy azért nem voltam
így egyedül vagyis nem vagyok így
egyedül a bloom style ajánlataik között
ott van az hogy esetleg elmész vásárolni
valakivel persze persze abszolút valós
reális lehetőség ez és a a közös
vásárlás nem csak azt jelenti hogy
mondjuk udvarhelyen elmegyünk egy
meghatározott számú boltba hanem ann az
is részét képezi hogy online
összeállítjuk azt azokat a megnézzük
hogy mik azok a ruhadarabok amik
kellenek és akkor azokat online meg
lehet nézni ki lehet választani tehát
egy ajánlatot kap az éillető személy
mondjuk te amikor tudjuk hogy milyen
élethelyzetben milyen munka milyen
igények vannak hova szeretne eljutni és
akkor ennek megfelelően rakjuk össze a
ruhadarabokat egyébként férfiaknál
amikor eljönnek stílustanácsadásra a van
aki úgy jön hogy szín és testalkat és
akkor egy picit beszéljünk arról hogy
hogyan rakjuk össze a a ruhatárját akkor
pinterest boardot szoktam készíteni
nekik mert ugye vizuálisak a férfiak és
sokkal jobban látják annak függvényében
hogy milyen élethelyzetben vannak mire
vágynak hogyan szeretnének tovább lépni
és akkor pinterest boardokkal dolgozunk
és abból lehet nagyon szépen ismét egy
vásárlási listát is
összeállítani mert elmenni vásárolni
stílustanácsadóval nem azt jelenti hogy
ez is tetszik ez is tetszik vegyük meg
hanem a stílust tanácsadó egy listát
készít hogy mikre van szükség és azok h
nem kell feltétlenül megvenni azt nem
nem nem nem de hogy egyébként is lista
van hogy mi az ami szükséges tehát nem
impulzus vásárlásra megyünk hanem
tudatos vásárlásra
igen ez a rögtön a következő görcs jön
fel bennem hogy az online vásárlásnál
valamit megveszek és tuti hiába néz ki
így a a fényképen amikor felveszem
teljesen másképp néz ki mert a vonal nem
ott van tegyük fel a méret nem hiába
hogy 42-es és tudom hogy 42esek a attól
még kicsi ez hogy lehet akkor online
vásárolni minden darabnál ott szokott
lenni a centiben is a méret legtöbbször
csak lusták vagyunk ezeket megmérni és
megnézni viszont ha azt mondjuk hogy
online akarok vásárolni és meg akarom
spórolni a próbaidőszakot a fülkékbe
vagy az otthon kényelmét választom akkor
viszont nem spórolhatjuk ki azt hogy
megmérjük hogy mondjuk a válhosz mekkora
vagy az újhosz mekkora és megnézzük
online a az adott daraboknál is ha olyan
oldalról vásárolnál ahol ezek nincsenek
kiírva akkor én azt mondom hogy ne
vásárolj onnan hm tehát ez egy ilyen jó
szelekciós kritérium is hogy honnan
vásárolj versusz honnan ne
igen hát körbejártuk most már nagyjából
a a szín test színtanácsadást a
testatellemzést és a
stílustanácsadást számomra a akkor vált
ez bizonyossá hogy tényleg itt van
valami emlékszem hogy volt egy
csapatépítőnk szovátán és akkor akkor
leültél a a hölgyekkel a csapaton belül
félrevonultatok becsuktátok az ajtót
szóltatok hogy ez most egy kicsi feminin
környezet lesz itt most mind
családanyákról van szó és olyan
személyekről akiknek nem feltétlenül
nyugati szépség ideál alapján lehet
formázni a testüket és azt hiszem bár
egy ilyen női misztérium körbelengi de
azt hiszem hogy egy egy pezgőt is
megnyitott
igen igen csoportosnál szoktunk igen és
és különböző ruha elemeket próbáltatok
fel különböző stílusú ruhákat hoztál
kívülről lehetett hallani a kuncogást
meg a még addig a gyerekekkel voltunk
és és azután
miután kijöttetek onnan és az utána levő
napokban és hetekben az az egyrészt egy
misztikus dolog ami történt valami
valami rejtett dolog de határozottan az
amit említettél íg az elején a
beszélgetésünknek hogy az egész családot
megemelte emlékszem hogy a feleségemet
is megemelte másképp nézett a ruhákra
nyilván egy részét ki kellett rakni
utána és újakat kellett vásároljunk de
nem kellett akartun bocsánat p nagyon jó
nem kellett hanem most már akartun
szeretett volna és én is tehát rájöttem
arra hogy hogy ez valami ami a legjobb
befektetett pénz abszolút és valami
csodálatos dolog történt másképp nézett
magára üli és néz folyamatosan
a és ugyanez a visszajelzés jött a
legtöbb családból ahonnan nem jött
visszajelzés csak tehát negatív
visszajelzés egyáltalán nem jött és
maximum nem jött egyáltalán visszajelzés
ez
egy ez volt az a pont ahol a fejemben
átváltott hogy itt van valami valamil
valami olyan dolog ami ami felszabadult
valami ami addig kötött volt ami amire
még talán szavaim sincsenek egy kicsit
mesélnél h mi történt ott vagy pedig az
hagyjuk ebbe a misztikus kötbe bezáró
szívesen mesélek tulajdonképpen ugyanaz
történt mint minden testalkat elemzésnél
megnéztük a jellemzőit a testalkati
jellemzőit minden egyes hölgynek és ugye
itt számít az hogy hol a dereka mennyire
vékony vagy vastag a dereka ahogy
mondtam hogy a csontozat függvényében
milyen az alkata és miután ezeket mind
megtudtuk hogy milyen szoknyahoz száll
jól hogy milyen dekoltázs milyen új
forma mennyire hangsúlyozza a derekát
tehát hogy ezeket mind meghatároztuk és
kacagjuk azóta is amikor találkozunk
mondják hogy igen mert annak idején
mondtad hogy na most hogy megtaláltad a
derekadat tehát hogy az sem egyértelmű
egy nőnek hogy hol van a dereka igen hol
van azután gyakorlatba ültettük mindezt
a tudást és ruhákon keresztül néztük meg
hogy hogyan emelhetnénk ki mindazt ami
szép minden egyes nőn mert nincs olyan
hogy hogy valami ne leg tehát hogy ne
legyen szép mindenki úgy indul hogy nagy
a hasam széles a csípőm nem tudom kicsi
a fenekem nagy a fenekem akármi és utána
mikor meglátja hogy milyen ereje van a
ruháknak mert tudatosan tudjuk
irányítani a figyelmet azzal ahogyan
öltözünk és tudunk elrejteni és tudunk
kiemelni tulajdképpen a fókusz átmegy
nem azon görcsölünk hogy hogyan rejtsük
el ami nem tetszik
és legtöbbször annak az az eredménye
hogy még jobban kiemeljük hanem azon
lesz a fókusz hogy hogyan emeljem ki azt
ami szép rajtam és ezzel automatikusan
odairányítom a figyelmet azt mutatom meg
és abszolút háttérbe szorul az
ami zavar adott esetben mi van azzal a
hölggyel aki arra gondol hogy én nem
akarom feltétlenül hogy nézzenek tehát
kiemelem a azt ami szép rajtam és vajon
milyen szándékkal teszem ezt és hogy
vajon a az erotikus vonzalom amit
ugyancsak nyugatról lehet érezni
mintogyha minden szexuálisan túlfütött
lenne talán nem helyén való minden egyes
helyzetben vagyis a legtöbb helyzetben
pláne hogyha ha ha egy tegyük fel egy
biznisz körülménybe kör kontextusba
öltözöl fel így van nagyon jó a kérdés
mert mindig el is mondom a ruháknál hogy
a figyelmet te irányítod ha neked egy
nagy oltázsú a blúzod vagy ruhád van
vagy nagyon rövid az a szoknya akkor te
nem a fejedre fogod irányítani a
figyelmet vagyis azokra a gondolatokra
amiket meg szeretnél osztani a tudásodra
a tapasztalatodra fogod irányítani a
figyelmet hanem a nőiességedre és a
nőiességednek egy olyan formájára amivel
lehet hogy azt üzened magadról hogy
párkeresőben
vagyok ha te azt szeretnéd hogy nőként
lássanak de ne arra menjen a figyelem
hanem a fejedre tehát a tudásodra a
tapasztalatodra az ismeretedre mert ez
az amivel a leggyakrabban találkozom
hogy ugye a régi szlogán hogy a itt a
fejem ide nézne
ide abban én is tehetek róla mert hogyha
minden itt van és akkor itt van egy nagy
felirat van egy nagy
dekoltázs lekapok mindent magamról és
csak az látszik akkor sem a férfinek de
a nőnek sem a másik veled szemben lévő
nőnek nem lesz könnyű rád nézni a
szemedbe nézni de akkor nem is arra fog
figyelni hogy mit mondasz és pont az
alpolgármesterség volt az ami még jobban
tudatosította ezt bennem mert ez egy
nagyon maszkulin környezet volt és ott
például tudatosan figyeltem arra hogy ne
legyek túl dekoltált dolgokban mert el
kellett hajolni egy vízért egy valamiért
és hogy ne haladja meg azt a szintet
egyébként is kakuktojás voltam nőként de
hogy erre ne erősítsek rá még jobban
azzal hogy nagyon túl feminin a a a
öltözékben vagyok túl szűk túl feszes
túl rövid túl médekoltás hanem a feminin
feminin oldalamat megőriztem tehát
ugyanúgy szoknyát vettem vagy inget
vettem csak figyeltem arra hogy a
dekoltázs ne legyen akkora vagy akár egy
zakóval egy picit enyhítettem a a
vonalakat de hogy alapvetően az
öltözködésünkkel mi határozzuk meg azt
hogy hova figyeljenek az emberek a
fejünkre a gondolat inkra a tudásunkra a
tapasztalatunkra a testünkre a hasunkra
a lábainkra egy élénk színű különleges
cipővel egyértelműen a figyelmet a
lábunkra fogjuk vinni egy különleges
erős színű a ővvel a figyelmet a
derekunkra fogjuk hogyha mi jól
választjuk meg a derékhangsúlyozást a
felsőnek a választását és a dekoltást
azzal nagyon szépen felfele tudjuk
irányítani a figyelmet az arcunkra
önmagunkat megmutatni nem egyik vagy
másik végletünket szoktam mesélni nekik
amikor a szoknyahosszakat nézzük hogy na
oké ez az a hossz amivel már a párodnak
kedveskedsz és nem a nem a külvilágnak
nagyon érdekes hogy a eí
szervezetfejlesztéssel foglalkozva úgy
engem engem nagyon érdekel hogy egy-egy
cégkultúra milyen és belül a kultúráb
látni a különböző személyeket és azt
látom hogy ez az öltözködésre is kihat
egy cégkult
kultúra találkoztam olyan szervezeti
kultúrával ahol a nők abba az irányba
vannak eltolva hogy egyre erotikusan
vonzóbbá váljanak és úgy nagyon
elgondolkoztatott hogyha tegyük fel most
felkérnének arra hogy ezt a szervezeti
kultúrát lassan megváltoztassam hogyan
tudnék beszélni ezekkel a hölgyekkel
hogy ahogyan öltözködnek ez nem
megfelelő szerintem tehát hogy nem tudsz
megváltoztatni valakit hogyha ő nem ak
akar változni hát de kötelezni lehet
kötelezni lehet igen és a dresskódok
nagyon sok helyen pont innen származnak
tehát hogy amikor azt mondják hogy
bankban vagy
különböző helyeken hogyan kell
megjelenni van ahol a színeket is
meghatározzák és van ahol a
szabásvonalakat is
meghatározzák viszont a az a kérdés
hogy mikor egy nő nagyon erotikusan
dolgozik egy munkakörnyezetben akkor
számomra ez azért fáj mert a nőt
eszközként használják és a nő egy
munkakörnyezetben nem eszköz hanem ő egy
teljes értékű tagja annak a közösségnek
ahol értéket teremt a szónak a nemes
értelmében és akkor pont azt az értéket
dugjuk el és rejtjük el a nőiessége mögé
úgyhogy én valahonnan innen indulnék el
hogy mi az amit amit üzenni akarunk a
világnak a férfi és a női
munkatársainkon keresztül is itt van egy
témakör amibe lehet nem kéne belemenni
de én csak bele fogok menni és félkész
válaszaim vannak annál is inkább inkább
csak úgy járjuk körbe kíváncsi vagyok a
véleményedre hogy ha biznisz körülmények
között maga az erotika az nem egy cél
most nyilván használhatják de ez egy én
én nem tartom egy szerencsés dolognak
hogyha
megjelenik mit kezdünk az
olyan olyan eszközökkel amik
egyértelműen erotikus szimbólumok
például a ú az a a a a kipirosodott ajak
az maga egy utal a szexuális
felajzottságra ugyanígy a a magas
sarkúcipő amelyik kiemeli a
csípőt és tehát vonzóbbá teeh erotikus
szempontból vonzóbá teszi és a smink is
ilyen szempontból hogyha tegyük fel
kipirosítjuk a bőrt akkor fiatalabbnak
életerősebbnek és ugyancsak úgy ahogy a
rús esetében a egy egy egy felajzott
állapotra
egésségesebbnek talán egés de de a rús
az az éppen nem feltétlenül az
egészséget több mint az egészség mert
nyilván az hogyha valaki szexuális
aktusra készen áll nem csak egészséges
de minimum egészséges tehát hogy hogy
itt hol látod a határt hogy hol lehetne
meghúzni mert mert a férfiak esetében ez
bizonyos szempontból egy tehát hogy
könnyebb eset a nők esetében viszont van
egy olyan éles határ vagy bocsánat egy
olyan finom határ amit nem nagyon tudok
hol meghúzni
pontosanm a stílus az nem csak a
ruháinknak az összessége ami rajtunk van
ugye az rengeteg döntésünknek a
megnyilvánulása stílus az is ahogyan az
ember megemeli a kávéscsészéjét vagogy
ahogy néz másnak a szemébe ahogy
viselkedik ahogy lép ahogy figyel a
másikra tehát ezek mind mind mind
részünket képezik éppen ezért csak a
ruha vagy csak a smink nem biztos hogy
elég erős fokmérője ha valaki nem nőies
és rá erőltetjük a női nagyon nőies
ruhát és a nagyon-nagyon ilyen típusú
sminket
diszkrepancia lesz tehát fogjuk érezni
hogy valami nem oké éppen ezért nehezen
értek én egyet ezzel például hogy ilyen
dresszkódok legyenek vagy hogy ilyen
nagyon-nagyon
lehetnek dresszkódok vagy lehetnek
limitek viszont az hogy milyen szín
milyen szabás pont azért mert nem
vagyunk egyformák mert nagyon-nagyon
sokfélék vagyunk nem tudunk ugyanolyan
szoknyát minden nőn nem fog jól állni na
fú bele keveredtem tehát ugyanaz a
szabásvonal különböző testalkatokon nem
lesz ugyanaz a hatás ugyanaz a rúzs
ugyanaz a smink típus másmás nőkön nem
lesz ugyanolyan egy sportos egy
romantikus egy alapvetően vonzóbb
nőtípuson egészen másképp fog hatni
ugyanaz a rúzs tehát itt nem csak a
smink önmagában számít a pirosító hanem
a stílusa hogy milyen az a nő hogy tud-e
önazonos lenni azokkal a dolgokkal vagy
vagy valahogy szétválik tudod a ruhák és
a smink külön van és a nő maga egészen
külön van tehát én azt mondanám hogy ez
az a határ ahol ahol érzed azt hogy tud
élni vele tud vele mozogni és önazonosan
megmutatja őt az a smink és az a ruha
vagy pont hogy elnyomni próbálja vagy
elrejteni próbálja mert amikor már túl
sok van belőle akkor már lehet hogy egy
egészen más dologról beszél mint mint
amiről egyébként az a nő beszél jyaníom
én is erről van szó hogy amikor valaki
ennyire kihívóan öltözködik valójában
valamint más z ő már ez a kiabáló tudod
igen és akkor az van hogy oké vettem
rendben van
megnéztelek végigsétáltattam a szemem
rajtad jöhet a
következő viszont hogyha valami olyan
van azon a nőn ami
úgy megfog ugye a franciákis mondják
hogy az a az a nem tudom mi benne van a
nőben akkor kíváncsivá tesz hogy
téged hogy még többet tudjál meg róla
hogy megismerd hogy mire gondol hogy
milyen elképzelései vannak és akkor már
egy egészen más síkra is tereli az
egészet hogyha most egy család tegyük
fel maga a családfő
úgy érzi hogy ez nagyon érdekes teljesen
új dolgokat hallottam
most én nagyon szeretném hogyha a
feleségem például elindulna ezen az úton
de tudom hogy elteltek az évek és úgy
nem nagyon foglalkozott vele az
önbecsülése is ilyen szempontból a
hóvirágnak a az
alsó formáját hozza hogy szeretném
valahogy bátorítani ebbe mit tanácsolnál
hogy hogyan lehetne milyen milyen utat
kéne bejárjon ez a család hogyan lehetne
bátorítani és most nyilván itt ilyen
szempontból én azt tudnám tanácsolni h
vásároljanak egy ajándékutalványt de ez
ez nem n csak egy nem csak egy pénzügyi
tranzakció valójában ez egy közös kaland
amiben a gondolom hogy a család részt
kell vegyen tehát hogyha a férfi nem
nyitott sőt talán még bünteti is a
feleségét hogyha valami valamivel
próbálkozik mert nyilván amikor valaki
próbálkozik akkor mellényúl néha néha és
és hogyha mellényúl és egyből
megszégyenítjük érte akkor gyakorlatilag
megtanítottuk hogy ha eddig szürke
voltál hogyan legyél még szürkébb így
van úgyhogy egy kicsit egy egy egy ilyen
case studyt vagy egy ilyen egy ilyen
utat be tudnám mutatni hogy hogyan
emelkedhetne fel egy
család
próbálok a stílust vagy megtanulni
stílusosnak lenni vagy öltözni igazából
kiemelni azt ami bennünk van azt úgy
szoktam elmondani hogy úgy képzeljék el
mint a főzéstanulást tehát akkor amikor
megtanuljuk mit jelent dinztelni milyen
íze van a hagymának milyen mi fog
történni a murokkal hogyha ha
lereszeljük és
beletesszük egy ételbe milyen az állaga
a nyers karalábénak és a fődt
karalábénak és így tovább és így tovább
hogyha ezeket tudjuk akkor nagyobb
eséllyel fogunk tudni egy recept mentén
megfőzni egy ételt ugye ha ismerjük az
alapösszetevőket azoknak a a változását
a kémiai hatás eredményeként és hogy
hogyan recept után össze tudunk rakni
egy egy ebédet minél többet gyakoroljuk
azt az ételformát vagy az ételek
készítését annál kevés lesz szükségünk
pontos receptekre és annál lazábban
fogjuk tudni ezeket az ételeket megfőzni
aztán elérünk arra a szintre amikor már
túllépünk a recepten mert a saját
kreativitásunkat és ízvilágunkat fogjuk
beletenni abba az ételbe és mondjuk a
klasszikus húslevesbe gyömbért is
teszünk vagy tudom is én borsikafűt meg
satöbbi satöbbi tehát hogy ugyanez
történik az öltözködéssel is vagy egy nő
vagy egy férfi életében amikor elindul
ezen az úton egyszer meg kell tanulni az
alapokat az alapok a színeink a
testalkati jellegzetességeink hogy
milyenek azok mit kezdjünk ezekkel és
hogyan viselkednek ezek különböző
ruhákon különböző környezetben különböző
szabásvonalakkal és hogyha ezeket tudjuk
akkor lesznek már kész receptjeink van a
pont a pinterest például vagy
instagramon hasonló
testalkatú nőket hogyha megfigyelünk
hogy hogyan öltöznek ezek már ötletet
adnak és lehetőséget hogy tudjuk
használni a meglévő tudásunkat és ebből
főzzünk és eljön az a pillanat amikor
már a stílus vagy ezek az információk
nem szabályként kereteznek be hanem
megnyitják a teret hogy a valódi
önmagunkat mutassuk meg valahogy ez
történik ez ez nagyon érdekes mert
mögött egy alapel van hogy bármilyen
területen csak akkor tudsz változtatni
hogyha rendszer mestere vagy tehát hogy
ha érted hogy mi történik csak akkor ha
ha szabályokat érted akkor meg lehet
szegni a szabályokat pont így van így
van abszolút abszolút és pont picasso
mondta azt hiszem hogy tanuld meg a
szabályokat olyan jól hogy majd utána
tehát hogy profiként tanuld meg a
szabályokat hogy majd művészként tudd
áthágni ezeket ez a cél üüm hogy
mindenki persze közülünk vannak akik
mindig megmaradnak a receptes főzött
ételek él és lesznek akik
misláncsillagos séfek lesznek tehát hogy
k megvannak ezek az különbségek de
senkinek nem fog a családja éhen halni
mert nem tud főzni ugyanígy a stílusban
is senki sem fog leragadni valahol a
szürkeségben hanem ki fog bontakozni
ebben a ki bontakozásban előfordul hogy
a nők olyan részüket oldalukat ismerik
meg és hozzák a felszínre ami nem biztos
hogy egyből tetszik a férnek otthon
igen ez egy olyan változás ahol együtt
kell változni és akkor például hogyha ők
szeretnének akkor pont azt javaslom hogy
egy ilyen páros stílustanácsadásra
jöjjenek el ahol azt kapják ajándékba
bár egyértelmű hogy mégis egy picit más
szemmel fognak nézni a párjukra a
társukra a picit az én szemüvegemen
keresztül is fogják látni nem csak a
színeikben a testalkatukban hanem abban
ahogyan ő akkor egy alkalommal
végigmentek a szín szín é testalkat igen
és akkor keretén belül a ez mennyi időt
vesz
igénybe hát hogyha párosan jönnek ez egy
ez egy jó délelőtt ez azt jelenti hogy
9-11yig csak ezzel foglalkozunk ühüm és
sokkal hamarabb elrepül az idő mint
gondolnák mindig az ennyi idő tehát mit
fogunk csinálni ajjaj a végén a végén
már sajnálni fogják hogy na hát hogy már
kész ennyi lejárt és ezt ezt úgy
képzeljem el mint egy
pszichológus rendelését hogy hat hetente
vissza kell járni nem nem ez ugye tehát
hogy a színeink mivel nem változnak a
testalkatunk mivel hízással fogyással
sem fog változni ezért ezek a dolgok sem
változnak egy ilyen tanácsadás ez egy
életben egyszeri alkalom úgy fogalmaznék
úgyhogy egyszer kell ebbe befektetni és
ezeket megismerni aztán nyilván vannak
kiegészítő termékek vannak még képzések
van még egy csomó minden amit mellé
lehet tenni és amivel ki lehet majd
egészíteni de az alap tanfolyam az az
életben egyszer kell
igen nagyon érdekes mert tényleg ezt
sokszor tapasztalom hogy
egyszerre szeretne a férj egy
vonzó jókedvű csinos feleséget maga
mellett és egyszerre nem hajlandó nyitni
az esztétika fele és nem és és azonnal
megszégyeníti a feleségét ahogy valami
olyasmit vesz fel ami elsőre talán még
diszonás is és annyira diszonás tegyük
fel hogy hogy hogy a fér is észreveszi
úgyhogy vagy csak egyszerűen szokatlan a
számára é megengedi magának vagyegz p
elmondani hogy szerinte az jó vagy nem
holott sem stílustanácselői
alapképzettsége nincs sem egyéb ami
feljogosítaná arra hogy sokszor
beletiporjon abba a nőbe aki ott van
mellette belpor igen ez ez azért is
foglalkoztatott engem ez a ez az egész
téma ezért is hívtalak meg mert
ugyancsak be még egyszer bebizonyos ik
hogy semmi sem csak annyi mint aminek
látszik gyakorlatilag ez az egész
témakör szorosan összefügg az
önbecsülésünkkel a világképünkel abs az
önbizalmunkkal az önbizalmunkkal
hogy amikor elkezdünk ezen az úton járni
vagy egy pont egy egy házastárs is
csatlakozik és együtt kezdenek el
elindulni valójában mélyen nagyon-nagyon
mély dolgokat fog mozgatnak meg amire
talán még szavaik sincsenek és láttál
ilyen történetek eg esetleg egy kedvenc
történetet meg minden történetem kedvenc
mert olyan szép az ahogy megnyílnak
ahogy meglátják a saját szépségüket de a
múlt héten volt nálam valaki aki úgy
jött be hogy
a mikor megállt a tükör előtt és akkor
azzal szoktam kezdeni és javaslom
mindenkinek hogy álljon meg a tükör
előtt és mondjon három dolgot amit
szeret a
testén és elkezdett
írni mertogy neki nincs a nem tud
megfogalmazni három dolgot amit szeret a
testén és akkor mondtam én többet is ami
szerintem szép
rajta aztán egy nem a haját mondta és
akkor a haján túl már nem nem nem
ment viszont ez egy érdekes történet
mert van egy másik szerelemojektem ami
az életvonal és a daganatos betegek
beteg nőknek a kezelé során legtöbbször
például a hajukkal azonosítják a
szépségüket és egy kemós kezelés után a
hajuk elhúl és akkor ezzel a szépségük
elveszítését is megélik úgyhogy ez egy
izgalmas téma egyébként de hogy ez a
fiatal nő aki nemrég ment
férhez a végén
állt a tükör előtt és úgy forgolódott
abban a tükörben mint egy négy-öt éves
kislány akire még nem mondták el hogy
hogy mekkora kéne legyen hogy milyen
kéne legyen hogy hanem azzal az ártatlan
szelídséggel nézi magát amivel szépnek
látja magát a tükörben és nem azon
gondolkodik hogy az ötéves a kislányok
átlagsúlyához képest ő több vagy
kevesebb a feneke kerekebb vagy laposabb
hanem csak egyszerűen szépnek látja
magát és a folyamat végére ez a nagyon
kedves kliensem is ezt látta a tükörbe
az öt éves kislánya
saját személye köszönt vissza és
mosolygott neki és nem a könnyei hulltak
hanem hanem mosolygott önmagának a
tükörbe és mondta hogy ezt lefotózod és
ezt is légyszi hogy akkor nehogy
elfelejtsem h
úgyhogy egy metamorfózis tényleg az ami
ami zajlik és minden történet ilyen
kedves vagy aki még visszaír hogy ezt
vettem és né vagy akinek a sztoriban
meglátom hogy felvette azt a darabot
amiről azt mondta hogy jaj én ezt soha
nem próbálnám fel és akkor jelzek neki
hogy láttalak vagy mindenig történet
külön a külön külön egyediségében szép
ahogy minden nő is milyen szép ebben a
történetben ezt az őszinte örömöt
önmagáb látod és hányszor lehet hallani
azt a hangot hogy ez hiúság ez hiúság
hogy hogy mintha nem szabadna örülnünk
önmagunak meg ez a székely nép népi
szemlélet
igen
ez ez az önbizalom nem az önértékelés
nem az önbecsülés ez az önbizalom amikor
vissza tudsz mosolyogni magadnak a
tükörbe mert az amit látsz az az úgy jó
és az úgy szép és hogy megérdemlem hogy
szépen felöltözzek
igen megemlítetted ezt az életvonalat ez
egy nagyon érdekes kezdeményez és
részben értem hogy miről szól de kicsit
kibontanád talán így záró utolsó öt
percként is e szerintem egy nagyon
érdekes és szép történet hogy hogy ezzel
fejezzük be igen és egy ráadásul egy
abszolút közösségi kezdeményezés és
összefogás eredménye hiszen az szka
odaadó estjén gyűlt össze az a pénz
amivel most dolgozni tudunk ennek a
projektnek a célja hogy a daganatos
betegségben lévő kezelés alatt után lévő
nőket egy
picit
megemeljen azzal
hogy
szépségipari szakmában lévő nőket
képzünk arra hogy bánni tudjanak
daganatos betegekkel fodrász kozmetikus
manikűrpedikűrős de most már pilátesz
oktató is akar csatlakozni a csapathoz
úgyhogy nagyon szépen kerekedik ez az
egész és az a célunk hogy daganatos
betegségben lévő nők is a szépnek lássák
magukat hogy
életminőségükben jobban legyenek abban a
nehéz időszakban is amit a betegség és a
kezelés a a időszaka jelent hogy az
értékük az önértéküket az
önbizalmukat picit így is úgy is
elveszítik de kezdjék el újraépíteni egy
olyan biztonságos segítő szerető
környezetben mint amilyenek a szépészeti
szakemberek úgyhogy a célunk az hogy a
képzett szépészeti szakembereket meg
fogjuk hirdetni akik önkéntesen
vállalnak daganatos beteg nőket most
elsősorban a nőkön van a
hangsúly és majd március végén
szeretnénk egy ilyen egy vagy két napos
tábort is szervezni számunkra ahol kicsi
smink kicsi frizura kicsi öltözés mert
stílustanácsadóként én is meg még van
stílustanácsadó kolléga aki részt vesz a
projekten tehát mi is önkéntes alapon
végezzük el ezt a munkát felöltöztetjük
őket és majd egy profi fotós jön és
portrékat fog készíteni róluk hogy
megünnepeljük azt a pillanatot ahol
vannak abban az utazásban lehet
hogy annak az utazásnak
úgy ahogy édesanyámmal volt nem lesz
hosszú a közös út de lehet hogy egy
nagyon-nagyon hosszú közös út lesz és az
egy mérföldkő az egy stáció az egy
pillanat amikor
megemlékezünk nekem például azt
említettem hogy édesanyámat daganatos
betegségbe veszítettem el nagyon
hiányzik hogy megmutathassam a főleg a
kisfiamnak egy olyan fotót ahol már
beteg de még nincs rosszul végletekben
vannak fotóim róla vagy nagyon nehéz
volt például amikor a temetésére
készültünk és kerestünk egy fotót róla
mennyivel szebb lett volna hogyha van
egy olyan fotó ahol ő is önazonosan ott
van és azt mondja hogy tudom hogy beteg
vagyok de ezt hagyom
nektek és akkor ezt a lehetőséget
szeretnénk megteremteni nem feltétlenül
ezzel a végkimenetellel mert azért azóta
már annyi minden változott és az
orvostudomány is változott és ú sok
minden van amivel most elsősorban
tabumentesíteni szeretnénk a daganatos
betegséget a velejáró a kezeléssel járó
következményeket és felkarolni a nőket
hogy jól érezzék magukat a
lehetőségekhez mérten és méltósággal
tudjanak járni kellni a világban tehát
hogyha jól értettem akkor két
célközönsége van ennek a projektnek a
szépészeti szakemberek először is hogy
csatlakozzanak így van így van és a és
mag azt elmondom hogy a facebook az
életvonal a facebook oldalt hogyha
megkeresik akkor ott egy találnak egy
kérdőívet is ahol csatlakozni tudnak
úgyhogy jelezni tudják a szándékukat
úgyhogy igen ők az egyik célcsoport és a
másik a daganatos beteg nők ők hogy
jöjjenek és éljenek ezekkel a
lehetőségekkel köszönöm neked ezt az
elmúlt másfél órát
sokkal több mindent tudtam meg annak
ellenére hogy több sokat beszélgetünk
sokkal több mindent tudtam meg erről a a
a a erről a szeletedről is ami
viszonylag egy vékony szeleted ahhoz
képest hogy mennyi minden másról is
beszélgethettünk volna most én nagyon
hálás vagyok és így így is át tudtuk
adni tényleg az a a személyes missziód
így teljesedik be hogy minden
területeden az élet színvonalat az
életminőséget próbálod emelni és ezek
mind nagyon szép kezdeményezések úgyhogy
a kedves hallgatókat bátorítom hogy
foglalkozzatok ezzel a témával és
keressétek fel a bloomsty.ro-t ugye igen
bloomsty.ro-t és és kezdjetek el
foglalkozni ezekkel a dolgokkal amik
annyi ideig ebbe a posztkommunista
időszakunkban annyi ideig meghatározta
és talán még most is meghatározza az
életünket úgyhogy köszönöm szépen még
egyszer kinga hogy a vendégem voltál én
köszönöm hogy kíváncsi voltál ha
tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz fel
kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket köszönjük a
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre